british
12 o'clock on the 4th of april
after you refuse our first request
uh considering that it is
impossible
to blatantly
a decision that wasn't coordinated with
anyone that it would be better to
discuss this topic today this is
an outrageous situation
uh said out in my
letter to you yesterday as an official
document of the council i would like to
ask you on what basis
you
feel that you can act in such an
outrageous way
existing norms and rules don't you know
that that in case you don't agree with
our proposal you should have convened a
meeting
forward
the issue of the advisability of holding
a meeting
especially since you should have
had before you the example of our
presidency where we didn't refuse a
single time
and we hope that in the future you will
not challenge the right of members of
the security council to request the
uh
of the security council at the request
of any member of the security council
well there he was thank you
i thank the representative of the
russian federation
is there anyone else who wants to
comment on this i will uh explain uh the
presidency's position in just a moment
okay
if i could
respond to your points
uh
from the ruston federation we did
not reject your request for a meeting we
received your letter
on sunday and it is the responsibility
with the obligation of the presidency to
schedule a meeting
you particularly requested a meeting for
a time on monday
our proposal as presidency was to
schedule the meeting either alongside
the meeting today so well within the 48
hour limit which is the convention of
the security council
or to hold the meetings sequentially one
after the other and i understand that
the russian federation turned down both
proposals but i wish to be clear that we
did not reject the request for a meeting
the deferral proposed was
less than 24 hours
and
to be clear
we share the view that this is an urgent
situation
and we have as i say offered the russian
federation either a separate meeting
today or to combine it with this one and
so as far as the presidency is concerned
we did
everything in line with the provisional
rules of procedure
and with precedent we have received no
other complaints from council members on
the subject
i give the floor to the russian
federation
we have evidence
if anyone
i thank the representative of the
russian federation uh the presidency
will not refuse to host meetings uh in
the future
and i hope that that now closes that
point and we can proceed with the
adoption of the agenda
the provisional agenda for this meeting
is letter dated the 28th of february
2014 from the permanent representative
of ukraine to the united nations
addressed to the president of the
security council s slash 2014-136
the agenda is adopted
i should like to start by
taking the opportunity to pay tribute on
behalf of this council
to her excellency lana nasa the
permanent representative of the united
arab emirates
for your service as the president of the
council for the month of march
i'm sure i speak for all of us
in expressing our deep appreciation to
ambassador sabre and her team
for the skillful uh conduct of the
council's business last month thank you
very much indeed to your team
in accordance with rule 37 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
i invite the representative of ukraine
to participate in this meeting
it is so decided
on behalf of the council i welcome the
participation of his excellency mr
vladimir zillienski the president of
ukraine
and just add that as usual precedent the
permanent representative of ukraine will
also join the meeting in case of any
technical issues
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
i invite the following briefers to
participate in this meeting
miss rosemary de carlo under secretary
general for political and peace building
affairs
and mr martin griffiths under secretary
general for humanitarian affairs
emergency relief coordinator
it is so decided
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
i also invite his excellency mr olof
skug head of delegation of the european
union to the united nations to
participate in this meeting
it is so decided
the security council will now begin its
consideration of item two of the agenda
i wish to warmly welcome his excellency
the secretary general his excellency mr
antonio gutierrez and i give him the
flaw
madam president
excellencies
the war in ukraine
is one of the greatest challenges ever
to the international order and the
global peace architecture founded on the
united nations charter
because of its nature
intensity and consequences
we are dealing with the full-fledged
invasion on several fronts of one member
state of united nations ukraine
by another the russian federation a
permanent member of security council
in violation of the united nations
charter
and with several aims including
redrawing the international recognized
borders between the two countries
the war has led to senseless loss of
life massive devastation in urban
centers
and the destruction of civilian
infrastructure
i will never forget the horrifying
images of civilians killed in butcher
and i immediately called for an
independent investigation to guarantee
effective accountability
and i'm also deeply shocked by the
personal testimony of rapes and sexual
violence that now are emerging
the high commissioner for human rights
has spoken of possible war crimes grave
breaches of international unitarian law
and serious violations of international
human rights law
and the russian offensive has also led
to the displacement of more than 10
million people in just one month
the fastest forced population movement
since the second world war
far beyond ukraine's borders the war has
led to massive increases in its price in
prices of food
energy and fertilizers because russia
and ukraine are linchpins of these
markets
it has disrupted supply chains and
increased the cost of transportation
putting even more pressure on the
developing world
many developing countries are already on
the verge of debt collapse due to the
impact of the coveted 19 pandemic and
the record adequate liquidity and debt
relief
stemming ultimately from the unfair
nature of our global economic and
financial system
for all these reasons it is more urgent
by the day to silence the guns
that is why ask the emergency leave
coordinator martin griffiths to travel
to russia and ukraine to press for an
urgent humanitarian ceasefire
and the secretary general griffiths will
update you on the humanitarian situation
and the results of his contact so far
and the secretary general dicarlo will
also brief you on the political and
human rights dimensions
but secretary general united nations it
is my duty to call the attention of the
council
to the serious damage being done to the
global economy and particularly to
vulnerable people and developing
countries
madam president
our analysis indicates that 74
developing countries with a total
population of 1.2 billion people
are particularly vulnerable to spiking
food energy and fertilizer costs
debt obligations take up some 16 percent
of developing countries export earnings
and in small island developing states
the figure is 34 percent and rising
because of increased interest rates and
the need to pay for expensive imports
in the past months alone which prices
have increased by 22 percent miles by 21
and barley by 31 percent
brent oil prices on the first of april
were more than 60 percent higher than at
the same time last year
a series of events have led to that not
only the present situation
natural gas and fertilizer prices more
than double over the same period
we are already seeing some countries
move from vulnerability into crisis and
signs of serious social unrest
the flames of conflict are fooled by
inequality deprivation and underfunding
with all the warning sign signals
flashing red we have a duty to act
madam president the global crisis
response group on food energy and
finance that i set up last month
has formulated some initial
recommendations for the consideration of
member states international financial
institutions and others
on food
we are urging all countries to keep
markets open resist unjustified and
unnecessary export restrictions and make
reserves available to countries at risk
of hunger and famine
this is not a time for protectionism
humanitarian appeals must be fully
funded
people crop up in crisis around the
world cannot pay the price for this war
on energy the use of strategic
stockpiles and additional reserves could
help ease this energy crisis in the
short term
but the only medium and long-term
solution
is to accelerate the deployment of
renewable energy which is not impacted
by market fluctuations
these will allow the progressive phase
out of coal and other fossil fuels
and renewables are already cheaper in
most of the cases and on finance
international financial institutions
must go into emergency mode
we need urgent action by the g20 and
international financial institutions to
increase liquidity and fiscal space
so that governments can provide safety
nets for the poorest and most vulnerable
the reform i've been calling for the
global financial system is long overdue
all these actions are closely linked
with the prevention agenda and with
building and sustaining peace
madam president the war in ukraine must
stop now
we need serious negotiations for peace
based on the principles of the united
nations charter
this council is charged with maintaining
peace and doing so in solidarity
i deeply regret the divisions that have
prevented security council from acting
not only on ukraine but on other threats
to peace and security around the world
i urge the council to do everything in
its power to end the war and to mitigate
its sin we need serious negotiations for
peace based on the principles of the
united nations charter
this council is charged with maintaining
peace and doing so in solidarity
i deeply regret the divisions that have
prevented security council from acting
not only on ukraine but on other threats
to peace and security around the world
i urge the council to do everything in
its power to end the war and to mitigate
its impact both on the suffering people
of ukraine and on vulnerable people and
developing countries around the world
and i thank you
i thank the secretary general for his
remarks
i now give the floor to mr rajamouti
carlo
thank you madam president since i last
briefed this council on 17 march the
security situation in ukraine has
seriously deteriorated
the number of ukrainian civilians killed
has more than doubled
ukrainian cities continued to be
mercilessly pounded often
indiscriminately by heavy artillery and
aerial bombardments
and hundreds of thousands of people
including children
the elderly and the disabled remain
trapped in encircled areas under
nightmarish conditions
the devastation brought on mariupol and
other ukrainian cities citiz cities
is one of the shameful hallmarks of this
senseless war
the horror deepened this past weekend as
shocking images emerged of dead
civilians some with hands bound lying in
the streets of bucha the town near kiev
formerly held by russian forces
many bodies were also found in a mass
grave in the same locality
reports by non-governmental
organizations in media also allege
summary execution of civilians rape and
looting insur nahith harkeef and kiev
regions
madam president away from the fighting
diplomatic efforts to end this war
including direct talks between ukrainian
and russian representatives have
continued
we commend the government of turkey for
hosting these discussions as well as the
efforts of many others engaging with
russia and ukraine to help bring about
peace
we welcome the willingness of the sides
to continue engaging to reach a mutual
understanding
this requires good faith and earnest
efforts
and progress in the negotiations should
be translated quickly into action on the
ground
while there has been a reported
reduction of russian troops in attacks
around kiev and chernikev
such moves should not be merely tactical
repositioning forces for renewed attacks
on ukrainian cities and towns elsewhere
the general assembly has twice called
for russian forces to withdraw entirely
from ukrainian territory and cease all
military operations
we also take note of the reported
withdrawal of russian forces from around
the chernobyl nuclear site
the international atomic energy agency
reports
that this development will hopefully
allow it to conduct an assistance and
support mission to provide technical
advice and to deliver equipment where
necessary as soon as possible
all nuclear sites in ukraine must be
fully protected and secured
military operations in around these
locations must be avoided
madam president
the numbers tell a tragic if yet
incomplete story
according to the office of the high
commissioner for human rights
at least 1
480 civilians have been killed and at
least 2
195 injured between 24 february and 4
april 2022
ohchr believes that the actual figures
are considerably higher
we are gravely concerned by the
persistent use of explosive weapons with
the wide impact area in or near
populated areas
such weapons are causing most civilian
casualties as well as massive
destruction of civilian infrastructure
including residential buildings
hospitals schools water stations and
electricity systems
ohchr has received credible allegations
that russian forces have used cluster
munitions in populated areas at least 24
times
allegations that ukrainian forces have
used such weapons are also being
investigated
as noted by the high commissioner
indiscriminate attacks are prohibited
under international humanitarian law and
may amount to war crimes
the massive destruction of civilian
objects and the high number of civilian
casualties strongly indicate that the
fundamental principles of distinction
proportionality and precaution have not
been sufficiently adhered to
in besieged cities a significant
increase in mortality rates among
civilians can also be attributed to the
disruption of medical care and basic
services
people with disabilities and the elderly
are particularly vulnerable
as of 4 april 2022 the world health
organization has reported a total of 85
attacks on health care facilities
resulting in at least 72 fatalities
and 43 injuries
madam president we are seriously
concerned about reports of cases of
arbitrary arrests and enforced
disappearances of persons who have been
vocal against the russian invasion
as of 30 march ohchr has documented the
arbitrary detention and possible
enforced disappearance of 22 journalists
and civil society members in kiev
hairsun luhansk and zapporigia regions
24 local officials have also been
detained in regions under russian
control
13 of whom have been subsequently
released
we call for the immediate release of all
individuals who have been arbitrarily
detained including journalists local
officials civil society activists and
others
also as of 30 march ohchr has recorded
seven journalists and media workers
killed since hostilities began
another 15 have come and come under
armed attack nine of whom were injured
allegations of conflict
related sexual violence perpetrated by
russian forces have also emerged these
include gang rape and rapes in front of
children
there are also claims of sexual violence
by ukrainian forces and civil defense
militias the u.n human rights monitoring
mission in ukraine continues to seek to
verify all these allegations
we're also concerned about distributed
videos depicting abuse of prisoners of
war on both sides
all prisoners of war must be treated
with dignity and full respect for their
rights in accordance with international
humanitarian law
madam president the many credible
allegations of serious violations of
international humanitarian law and
international human rights law from
areas recently retaken from russian
forces
must not go unanswered
we support efforts to examine these
allegations and to gather evidence
ensuring accountability and justice for
acts committed during the war will not
be easy but it is essential
madam president we are heartened by the
generosity of neighboring countries who
accepted millions of refugees and the
solidarity of ukrainian people who were
hosting their displaced compatriots
with more than 10 million people
displaced either within ukraine or
abroad as refugees roughly one quarter
of the population the united nations is
gravely concerned about the heightened
risk of human trafficking
indeed
suspected and verified cases of human
trafficking are surfacing in the
surrounding countries according to the
international organization for migration
madam president this war is devastating
ukraine now
but it also threatens its future
early assessment projections by undp
suggest that if the war continues
through 2022
ukraine faces the prospect of seeing 18
years of socioeconomic progress lost
this would set the country and the
region
back decades
and leave deep long-term social and
economic fissures
un agencies including undp are working
to help preserve ukraine's hard-worn
development aims gains
this involves supporting the government
to sustain
essential government structures and
basic services including emergency
measures to sustain livelihoods such as
cash-based assistance
madam president the war in ukraine has
damaged europe's security architecture
its economic repercussions are already
evident far from the battlefield
the longer the war continues the greater
the risk that it will further weaken the
global institutions and mechanisms
dedicated to preserve peace and security
the war was started by choice
there is no inevitability to it or to
the suffering it is causing
the united nations is ready to do
everything in its means to help bring an
end to it thank you madam president
i thank mr carlo for her
briefing and i now give the floor to mr
martin griffiths
thank you madam president um as you've
just heard from
the secretary general and under
secretary general de carlo
ukrainian civilians are paying
far too high price for this war
i want to speak briefly about
humanitarian needs and what we're doing
to meet them before i then
refer to my recent travels
in the last six weeks as we have heard
at least
1430 people
have been killed among them
over 121 children and we know this is
very likely a serious underestimate
homes and civilian infrastructure
bridges
hospitals
schools
have been damaged and destroyed
and in fact the current figures on
displacement
tell us that more than
11.3 million people have now been forced
to flee their homes and of that 4.2
million in our refugees
in those generous neighboring countries
that rosemary has just been referring to
so in total more than a quarter of the
population of ukraine has fled
in this extraordinary
a short time
and unfortunately we can imagine that
these figures
will continue to rise until we can find
a pause
and some peace madam president
the ground and air offensives and
counter offenses
are making life nearly impossible for
many civilians in ukraine
families the elderly women and children
have been trapped by fighting already
for too long
for more than five weeks
the people of mario paul have been
caught up in the fighting
and it is well documented that really
maripole is a center of hell
other cities like chernohev sumi and
kharkiv remain cut off from essential
goods and services
and perilous conditions are hampering
our efforts to access civilians or for
them to access us
and we restate here that civilians must
be allowed to move
to safer areas without the fear of
attacks
and at their own choice and at their own
selection
it's vital that all parties
to the conflict respect their
obligations under international
humanitarian law to protect civilians
and to allow impartial humanitarian
organizations safe
rapid unimpeded access to all civilians
in need wherever they are
in ukraine
madam president as the world watches
humanitarian needs saw in ukraine
the united nations
and our partner organizations
are making every effort to dramatically
increase our support to affected
civilians the work of the six thousand
volunteers
from the ukraine red cross as we have
noted before in this chamber together
with local ngos in eastern ukraine
these
people these organizations continue to
work tirelessly tirelessly at the front
line of assistance to communities
the world food programme has reached
more than 1.3 million people with cash
and food assistance and plans to push
that number up to two and a half million
people in this month
health partners report
that more than 180 tons of medical
supplies were delivered in ukraine
with another 470 tons
on the way
and this will address the health needs
of environment six million people
in the months ahead
and i'm pleased to say that seems an odd
word to say in the context
of ukraine that after much effort in the
past day another convoy
went from our humanitarian hub in
dinipro
to the far east
today food winter clothing non-food
items medicine hygiene kits were
offloaded to the ukraine red cross
and will reach the hands of those most
in need
indeed following notification
to both parties a formal process
that we and also the international red
cross are engaged in
four convoys in total from the un
have provided critical support to people
in some of the cities encircled by war
where on with and affected by ongoing
fighting several more are planned
so these are initial steps
but it gives us a basis to now expand
taking our efforts up to scale and
expanding much more than one convoy a
day
as the secretary general and the under
secretary general's already said
i want to also join them
in expressing my concern over the
growing number of reports we receive of
human trafficking
sexual violence exploitation and abuse
in ukraine and in the region
and as there are such horrific incidents
as we are seeing
there overwhelmingly impact displaced
women and children
more than others
we're bolstering protection and
gender-based violence services
through agencies to provide specialized
care for survivors
and through the the
the wealth of civil society
organizations
in ukraine
these services are designed carried out
directly in collaboration with and
through ukrainian civil society
including
very particularly women-led
organizations
madam president today i'm addressing you
from geneva
having just returned from moscow
overnight
as you know the secretary-general as he
said
charged me to bring both sides together
on humanitarian grounds to explore both
specific
and sustained ways to reduce
humanitarian suffering including in
particular
uh inter alia but in particular the
pursuit of a humanitarian ceasefire
yesterday in moscow
i had long and frank exchanges with the
minister of foreign affairs sergey
lavrov and his deputy sergey rashinin
and then separately with alexander
fuhrman the deputy minister of defense
in my meetings
with these senior officials
i discussed also in addition
to these possibilities of humanitarian
ceasefires
i discussed the issue of humanitarian
convoys of safe passage
including the four which we've i've
already referred to
i outlined possibilities for building
further on that cooperation
sharing specific
suggestions for mutually agreed upon
military freezes
to allow for evacuation of civilians and
for the safe passage of life-saving aid
in effect for humanitarian pauses in
different parts of ukraine to save lives
and bring back a modicum
of
safety for those living in those places
my counterparts in moscow received these
suggestions assured me of their intent
to carefully study those ideas which i
left with them
and we agreed to remain in close contact
and i came away from these meetings
believing that we have a very long road
a long road ahead of us
but it must be traveled
the melon president we will travel it
tomorrow i hope to travel i plan to
travel to ukraine
to have discussions with senior
authorities
from the ukrainian government in kiev on
thursday on these same issues and others
that they will no doubt present to me
and also to see firsthand with our
crisis coordinator amin awad
the humanitarian response
madam president
thanks to generous donor contributions
many from governments
in this chamber the humanitarian
response since february
has indeed been scaled up allowing us to
meet the needs of one and a half million
people
we will need sustained financial support
for needs in ukraine
and like the secretary-general i want to
stress
as he has done consistently that funding
must not be diverted from other crises
and madam president
for afghanistan that
as you heard from david beasley last
week conflict climate shocks covered
compounded by the soaring food and fuel
costs
indicated by the secretary general
could push another 47 million people
globally into severe food in security
and so the total number of people around
the world
who will not know where their next meal
comes from could be driven
to the astonishing figure of
325 million people around the world
that is by a long distance the highest
in our recent history and well over
double
what was what it was three years ago
so madam president i close of course
like others by reminding the council of
what the council already knows well
the world cannot afford this war
and neither can the people of ukraine
and like others i call on all council
members and member states with influence
to support all efforts from whatever
part they come from in the pursuit of
peace
and the alleviation of humanitarian
suffering for the sake of the people of
ukraine
for the sake of those around the world
who cannot afford to bear the additional
burden
this war imposes on them
and all of us we must as the secretary
general said
silence the guns thank you madam
president
i thank mr griffiths for his briefing
i now give the floor to his excellency
mr vladimir zelensky the president of
ukraine
you have the floor sir
thank you very much
dear madam
chairman
dear mr secretary general
distinguished members of the security
council and other members of this
meeting thank you very much for this
opportunity i'm sure that all the
representatives of the united nations
member states will hear me today
yesterday i returned from our city of
butcher recently liberated from russian
troops
not far from kiev so there is not a
single crime that they would not commit
there the russian military searched for
and purposefully killed anyone who
served our country they killed shot and
killed women outside their houses when
they just tried to call someone who is
alive they killed entire families adults
and children and they try to burn the
bodies
i am addressing you on behalf of the
people who honor the memory of the
deceased every single day in the memory
of the civilians who died who were shot
and killed in the back of their head
after being tortured some of them were
shot on the streets others were thrown
into the wells so they died there in
suffering they were killed in their
apartments houses blowing up grenades
the civilians were crushed by tanks
while sitting in the their cars in the
middle of the road
just for their pleasure they cut off
limbs cut their throat slashed their
throats women were raped and killed in
front of their children they were
their tongues were pulled out only
because the aggressor did not hear what
they wanted to hear from them so this is
no different from other
terrorists such as daesh who occupied
some territory and here it is done by a
member of the united nations security
council destroying internal
unity borders countries and taken the
right of more than dozens of countries
who are
self-determined and indeterminate they
pursue a consistent policy of destroying
ethnic and religious diversity then
inflame wars and deliberately lead them
in
such a way that to kill as many
regular
civilians and cities to
leave the country where they deploy
their troops in ruins and filled with
mass graves you all see that and they
support hatred at the level of the state
and seek to export it to other countries
through their system of propaganda and
political corruption they provoke a
global food crisis that could lead to
famine in africa asia
uh and other countries and will
surely end in large-scale political
chaos in many countries
were to and uh destroying
their domestic security
so where is the security that the
security council needs to guarantee it's
not there although there is a security
council um
and uh
so
where is the piece
where are those guarantees that the
united nation needs to guarantee it is
obvious that the key institution of the
world which must ensure
the coercion of any aggressor to peace
simply cannot
work effectively now the world can see
that the russian mil what russian
military did in bucha while keeping the
city under their occupation but the
world has yet to see what they have done
in other occupied cities and regions of
our country geography might be different
of various but cruelty is the same
crimes are the same and accountability
must be inevitable ladies and gentlemen
i would like to remind you of article 1
chapter 1 of the ui charter what is the
purpose of our organization its
purpose is to maintain peace and uh make
sure that uh peace is adhered to and now
the uncharted is violated literally
starting with the article one and if so
what is the point of all other articles
today as a result of russia's actions in
our country
in ukraine the most terrible war crimes
of all times are
we see
since the end of world war ii and they
are being committed russians troops are
deliberately destroying united ukrainian
cities
to ashes by with artillery and air
strike they are deliberately blocking
city creating mass starvation they
deliberately shoot columns of civilians
on the road trying to escape from the
territory of history hostilities they
even deliberately blow up shelters where
civilians hide from airstrikes they are
deliberately creating conditions in the
temporarily occupied territories so that
as many civilians as possible are killed
there uh the massacre in our city of
butcher is only one unfortunately only
one of many examples of what the
occupiers have been doing on our land
for the past 41 days and there are many
more cities similar places where the
world will has yet to learn the full
truth
and dozens other ukrainian communities
each of
them is similar to bucha i know and you
know perfectly well what the
representatives of russia will say in
response to the accusations of these
crimes they have said that many times
the most significant was after their
shooting down of the malaysian boying
over donbass by russian forces with
russian weapons or during the war in
syria they will blame everyone just to
justify their own actions they will say
that there are various
versions different versions and it is
impossible to establish which one of
those versions is true they will even
say that the bodies were
of those skills were allegedly thrown
away and all videos are staged but it is
2022 now
we have conclusive evidence so there are
satellite images
and we can conduct full and transparent
investigation that is what we are
interested in
maximum access for journalists maximum
cooperation with international
institutions involvement of the
international criminal court complete
truth and full accountability
i'm sure that every
member state of the un should be
interested in this for what in order to
punish once for and for all those who
consider themselves privileged and
believe that they
can
get away with anything so
show all the other potential war
criminals in the world how they will be
punished if the biggest one is punished
then everyone is punished
why did ukraine came to
come to ukraine i will tell you because
russia lead russia's leadership feels
like colonizers in ancient times they
need our wealth our people russia has
already deported hundreds of thousands
of our citizens to their country they
abducted more than 2 000 children just
simply conducted that those children and
continue to do so russia wants to turn
ukraine into silent slaves the russian
military are looting openly the cities
and villages that they have captured
this is widescale
looting they are stealing everything
starting with food
ending with earrings gold earrings that
are pulled out with blue and covered
with blood we are dealing with a state
that is turning the veto into the un
security council into the right to die
the this undermines the whole
architecture of global security it
allows them to go unpunished so they are
destroying everything that they can't so
this if we if this continues there
the countries will be
rely only on the power of their
own arms to ensure their security and
not on international law not rely on
international institutions the united
nations can be on simply closed ladies
and gentlemen are you ready to close the
un do you think that the time of
international law is gone if your answer
is no then you need to act immediately
the un uh charter must be restored
immediately the u.n system must be
reformed immediately so that the veto is
not the right to die that there is a
fair representation in the security
council of all regions of the world the
aggressor must be brought to peace
immediately determination is needed the
massacre from syria to somali somalia
from afghanistan to yemen and libya that
should have been stopped long time ago
to tell you the truth if tyranny had at
least once received such a response to
the war it had be we had waged it would
have ceased to exist and honest peace
had been guaranteed after it and the
world would have changed for sure and
then perhaps there would not be war in
my country against our people
against ukrainian people against
uh our citizens but the world watched
and did not want to see either the
occupation of crimea or the war against
georgia or taking the entire
transgistria from moldova and how russia
was preparing
the basis for other conflicts and wars
near their borders
how to stop it
right away the russian military and
those who gave them orders must be
brought to justice immediately for war
crimes in ukraine anyone who has given
criminal orders and carried out them by
killing our people will be
brought before the tribunal which should
be similar to the nuremberg tribunals i
would like to remind russian diplomats
that a
man
like uh von riben trump has not escaped
punishment after for crimes in world war
ii i would also like to remind you that
adolf arkman also did not uh go did not
go unpunished nobody uh of of them
escaped the punishment but the main
thing is today is to
it's time to transform this system
the united nations so therefore i
propose to convene a global conference
and we can do it here in peaceful cave
in order to determine how we are going
to reform the world security system how
we will rely
uh
how do we establish guarantee of
recognition of borders and integrity of
states and countries how we will assert
the rule of international law it is now
clear that the goals set in san
francisco in 1945 for the creation of a
global security international
organization have
not been achieved and it is impossible
to achieve them without reforms
therefore we must do everything in our
power to
pass on to the next generation an
effective un with the ability to respond
preventively to security challenges and
thus guarantee peace prevent aggression
and force aggressors to peace have the
determination and ability to punish if
the principles of peace are violated
there can be no more exceptions or
privileges everybody must be equal all
participants of international relations
regardless of economic strength
geographical area and individual
ambitions the power of peace must become
dominant the power of justice
and the security uh
power as
uh humanity has always dreamed of it
ukraine is ready to provide a platform
for one of the main offices of the a
newly uh updated security system as
similar to the geneva office that deals
with human rights nairobi office that
deals with environmental protection and
in kiev we can have
u24 office that can specialize in
preventive measures to maintain peace i
would like to remind you of our peaceful
mission in afghanistan when we
ukrainians evacuated from that country
over thousands more than 1 000 people
from uh uh with at our own extents it
was a very difficult phase and ukraine
uh came to their health we took in
people of different nationalities ethnic
groups different faith
afghan citizens of the the european of
european countries us canada
we did not look who needed
help was it one of our own or somebody
else we helped all of them we saved
everyone if every time there was a need
everyone in the world would be confident
that help could would come the world
would be definitely safer therefore
ukraine has the
the moral right to propose a reform of
the world security system we have proven
that we help others not only happy time
but in dark times too and now we need
decisions from the security council for
peace in ukraine if you do not know how
to uh
to make this decision you can do two
things
either remove russia as an aggressor and
a source of war
so it cannot block decisions about its
own aggression its own war
and then do everything that we can
do uh to establish peace or the other
option is please
show how we can
uh
reform or change dissolve yourself and
work for peace or if there is no
alternative and no option
then the next option would be dissolve
yourself all together
and i know that um you can admit that if
there is nothing that you can do besides
conversation we need peace we ukraine p
needs peace europe needs peace and the
world needs peace and finally i would
kindly ask you very much to s
watch this short video
please give us one more minute of your
time the video
that
we
want to show that
one
one country can violate
rights and that's
the result of being unpunished if
possible please watch this video because
it is impossible to get everyone to come
to our country and see it with your own
eyes therefore i would ask you to watch
this video thank you very much
[Applause]
they have the video
i'm not sure the
video is that just coming
uh uploaded to the technicians or
security council
so they have it in their position
i we
will
typically we don't have the video
proposed that while we sort that out
i thank his excellency mr zillienski for
his compelling and powerful remarks
we will come back to the video when
we've sorted out the technical uh the
technical issues around it and may i say
speaking in my national capacity
may i express appreciation to the
president
for his leadership in wartime and for
the extraordinary fortitude and bravery
of the ukrainian people under this
unprovoked and illegal invasion
i resume my function as the president of
the security council and while we sort
out the
technical video i propose to give the
floor to those council members who wish
to make statements
and i now give the floor to the
representative of the united states
thank you madam president
let me also start by thanking uae and
ambassador nisabe for her successful
presidency during the month of march
madam president
as you begin
your security council presidency i want
to thank the united kingdom
for your leadership and for organizing
this vital discussion on ukraine today
i also want to thank the secretary
general for his remarks
and the other briefers
and i'd like to extend a warm welcome to
president zielinski
i was so moved by the address he made
recently to our congress and we are
truly honored by his presence here under
the circumstances that he and ukraine
face today
madam president last night i returned
from a trip to moldova and romania
i saw with my own eyes the refugee
crisis caused by russia's unconscionable
war
i spoke to refugees
who indicated to me their desires to
return to their home
and we've all seen the images on tv of
the bummed out buildings
but what we have not seen
is that behind those destroyed buildings
are destroyed lives
and destroyed families
i met with women and children who had
fled ukraine who stuffed their lives
into backpacks and left the only home
they had ever known
and these were sobering conversations
one young woman i spoke to came with her
six-year-old brother
who had autism and is struggling with
cancer
their single mother helped them escape
to save their lives
but russia's war has interrupted the
care her brother desperately needs
another woman i spoke to
fled with her eight-year-old from odessa
the father
who they'd left behind
told them they were shelling right next
to their apartment that very night
and they very well could have died had
they not
left
a third woman i met
told me that she used to love to travel
but never expected her next trip would
be to flee her life
flee for her life
when i asked her where she was from
she started to say and then she stopped
with tears in her eyes and said i'm
sorry i don't know how to say it whether
i live in kiev
or whether i used to live in kiev
she was realizing in the moment
just how dramatically her life had
changed because of this senseless war
these are three stories of more than 10
million
people
6 million internally displaced 4 million
who have left ukraine all together
four million people who have relied on
the big-heartedness of countries like
moldova romania poland slovakia hungary
and others across the region in the
world to welcome and support all those
leaving ukraine
in search of safety
ukraine's neighbors are bearing the
brunt of europe's most significant
refugee crisis since world war ii
and i want these countries to know that
they have a committed partner
in the united states
and that is why the united states
announced recently that we are prepared
to provide more than one billion us
dollars in new funding toward
humanitarian assistance for those
affected by russia's war in ukraine and
its severe impact around the world
and it is why we are welcoming up to a
hundred thousand ukrainians and others
fleeing russia's aggression to the
united states
we will continue to assist humanitarian
efforts to help the people of ukraine
and all those fleeing putin's violence
but as heart-wrenching as the stories
are that i heard in moldova and romania
there are some stories
we will never get to hear
those of the people we saw in the images
out of bucha
we've all seen the gruesome photos
lifeless bodies lying in the streets
apparently summarily executed
their hands tied behind their backs
as we work to independently confirm the
events depicted in these images i would
remind this council
that based on the currently available
information the united states has
assessed
that members of russia's forces have
committed war crimes in ukraine
and even before seeing the images from
bucha
president zielinski along with others in
the region were reporting that children
were being abducted and we heard him say
that today
also abducted are mayors and doctors
religious leaders journalists and all
who dare defy russia's aggression
some of them according to credible
reports including by the maryland city
council have been taken to so-called
filtration camps
where russian forces are reportedly
making tens of thousands of ukrainian
citizens relocate
to russia
reports indicate that russian
federal security agents are confiscating
passports
and ids
taking away cell phones and separating
families from one another
i do not need to spell out what these
so-called filtration camps are
reminiscent of
it's chilling
and we cannot look away
every day we see more and more how
little russia respects human rights
and that is why i announced yesterday
that the united states in coordination
with ukraine and many other u.n member
states will seek russia's suspension
from the u.n human rights council
given the growing mountain of evidence
russia should not have a position of
authority in a body whose purpose
whose very purpose
is to promote
respect for human rights
not only is this the height of hypocrisy
it is dangerous
russia is using its membership on the
human rights council as a platform for
propaganda to suggest russia has a
legitimate concern for human rights
in fact we will hear some of that
propaganda here today i know
and i will not dignify these lies with a
response only to say that every lie we
hear
from the russian representative is more
evidence that they do not belong on the
human rights council
140 u.n member states voted to condemn
russia over its unprovoked war and the
humanitarian crisis it has
unleashed
upon the people of ukraine
here's my message to all of you
now is the time to match those words
with action and show the world that we
can work responsibly
and i share president zielinski's view
that this moment requires responsible
world powers and global leaders to show
some backbone
and stand up to russia's dangerous and
unprovoked threat against ukraine and
the world
the secretary general said that
confronting this threat is the security
council's charge
it is
and it is also the responsibility of u.n
leaders and leaders around the world
every single member state with a voice
in the ga
no one
can be a shield for russia's aggression
suspending russia from the human rights
council is something we
collectively have the power to do in the
general assembly
our votes can make a real difference
russia's participation on the human
rights council
hurts the council's credibility
it undermines the entire u n
and it is just plain wrong
let us come together to do what is right
and do right
by the ukrainian people
let us take this step
to help them to start to rebuild their
lives
and let us match the courage of
president zielinski who we are so
honored to have with us today
president zielinski
i want you to know that we stand with
the people of ukraine
as you face down this brutal attack on
your sovereignty on your democracy and
on your freedom
thank you
i thank the representative of the united
states for her statement and i give the
floor to the representative of albania
thank you madam president
let me thank ambassador nussiber for
having steered our work during the month
of march and wish the uk a new madam
president
full success in our common work during
this month
albania welcomes president zelinski
presents to this meeting
his remarks are painful and his account
on what ukraine is experiencing under
russian occupation is revolting
we stand by you mr president
by your compatriots all ukrainians for
their heroic resistance for the
resilience that the entire world is
admiring
you are not alone
you have the world on your side because
it's the raw is the side of the right
of the just and as we hope of victory
slavokrani
madam president let me thank sg
gutierrez for his again very clear and
powerful remarks
i also thank usg carlo and griffith
for their updates
this is the 14th meeting of the security
council on ukraine since the 31st of
january while the war of aggression has
entered the second month
let's establish a few basic yet
meaningful facts
russia has stalled and its imperial
dreams are nowhere
taking ukraine finally proved impossible
kiev was too hard to swallow
russian army is in disarray but it has
not stopped shelling and bombardments
but all this is not new and all this is
not news
the real news that has horrified the
world is what russia is leaving behind
the unspeakable horrors those
soul-crushing images in areas from which
russia is withdrawing
images of civilians executed with a
bullet in the neck
sometimes with their hands tied behind
their backs or shot dead in their
bicycles
images of mass graves overflowing with
corpses
images of carnage and devastation
including looted homes rape and sexual
violence
acts usually attributed only to thugs
they spring from the same cruel impulses
as the bombardment of cities homes
hospitals schools and kindergartens by
the russian forces
bucha is an open-air graveyard
the notorious facelift of the russian
aggression
madam president
we have heard
time and again
it is not russia
yes but no
it will be hard actually impossible to
convince anyone
that the destroyed tanks that clutter
the roads
the mines and booby traps left behind
amid the wreckage and the bodies of
civilians killed by arbitrary executions
and laying in the streets amidst debris
are staged scenes for propaganda
who would believe that russia aggressed
ukraine simply to protect civilians
while ukraine is busy staging horror
movies
you may muzzle media back home
but you cannot fool satellite images you
cannot blind independent reporters and
human rights ngos on the ground
waiting for russia to accept and tell
the truth
is waiting for godot to arrive
and he never does
these are facts hard and sickening proof
of the atrocities committed the ugly
face of this madness
such crimes as documented by human
rights watch and verified by independent
and respected professional reporters
those who are banned for the russians
call for answers
call for federal investigation for
effective accountability for justice
prime minister rama called these crimes
a terrible pain and a horrible shame
russia has an international obligation
to abide by international militant law
the laws of war including the geneva
conventions of 49 and its first
additional protocol
russia has an obligation to abide by the
order of icj to immediately hold its
military activity in ukraine
but unfortunately russia has made
another choice
not to respect any of it
and has cancelled itself from
international law
but the law will pursue it
russian army and its commanders cannot
escape accountability
the name of the butcher of maripol
a criminal that has reduced an entire
city to ashes
and has made its citizens go from three
meals a day to barely three meals a week
is engraved in the ruins of the city
this is why we will support the call to
suspend russia's participation in the
human rights council
the unga resolution that created the
council stipulates that and i quote
members of the council will respect the
highest standards in the promotion and
protection of human rights
as we see
russia's standards are nose eating and
its presence there is a first
a desecration of the place that is
called to be the sanctuary of rights
dear colleagues
russia has announced that it will now
shift its focus on eastern ukraine this
means that it will concentrate its
brutality there in what may end up
becoming a war of attrition
russia has blocked the renewal of the
osce international
observer mission in ukraine
this denies the international community
the independent eyes it needs there
this anticipates sadly more war
further atrocities other crimes even
more humanitarian disasters
this war continues to particularly
affect women and children
millions have been displaced many of
them alone in search of safety and
security it is heartbreaking to see
mothers write names and addresses in the
back of their children
so that they are recognized in case they
end up being orphans
we welcome the efforts of osha and its
partners to deliver assistance in
support of the people in ukraine and the
millions of refugees in neighboring
countries
madam president let me end with this
note
rarely has the outcome of a war been so
disastrously the up the complete
opposite of what it wanted to achieve
russia's army has been defeated by the
outgunned and outnumbered ukrainian
resistance
russia is isolated like never in its
history
it has become the world's most
sanctioned country in history
no country has ever seen itself
transform in a matter of only 10 days
from a global player
into a financial and international
pariah
to the point that it is obliged to find
comfort in the support from north korea
and syria
dear colleagues
this aggression is and its startling
defeat have once and for all separated
the fates of ukrainians and russians
because the case of ukraine is also the
cause of democracy against tyranny and
kleptocracy
it is a fight between the will of the
people against the will against the
vicious will of one
whose reckless actions have challenged
everything we stand for and who is
directly responsible for the economic
disruption and food insecurity which is
affecting the entire world
he may choose to stop withdraw troops
and quit ukraine
or continue to descend in the very abyss
he has created and faced the
consequences
i thank you
i thank the representative of albania
for his statement i understand that we
now have solved the technical problems
so i suggest we return to the video
thank you
[Music]
uh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i
would like to
thank
the delegation of ukraine
for
sharing
uh that video with us
the images are harrowing
speaking in my national capacity
we are appalled
by what we have seen
and reiterate our solidarity with
ukraine
i resume my function
as the council president
and i now give the floor to the
representative of gabon
i would like to at the outset
express my appreciation
to the ambassador of the united arab
emirates for her remarkable presidency
i thank the secretary general
mr antonio guterres
under secretary general madame rosemary
de carlo
as well as mr martin griffiths
for their respective briefings
i welcome the participation in this
meeting of
president zielinski madam president
we continue to witness powerless
the war in ukraine
while the grim toll of the dead and
displaced mounts
and fighting continues even as lives and
civilian infrastructure
are destroyed
day in day out
one day of war is one without a doubt
one day too many and as the conflict
enters its sixth week the number of
displaced persons
is now surpassing the ten million mark
almost four million of which have sought
refuge in neighboring countries this is
a frightening
humanitarian catastrophe
the repercussions of will
of which are sure to worsen as a result
of the risks of food insecurity due to
the unpredictability of harvests
which will in turn have trans-regional
knock-on effects
i'd like to welcome the secretary
general's uh establishment of a working
group task force on
uh food security energy and finance to
reduce the impact of the war madam
president
allegations concerning
violence and especially sexual violence
against women
are cause for grave very grave concern
my country is very concerned as well
at attacks against
infrastructure
and humanitarian personnel
humanitarian workers working in theaters
of conflict should never be the target
of armed attacks they are very often the
link between victims of war
and what remains of humanity when the
rug has been pulled from under their
feet
humanitarian workers should be able to
funnel humanitarian assistance to
wherever it is needed without obstacles
and in conditions of security guaranteed
by all parties
it
should be possible to form secure
evacuation convoys
to allow for the smooth
evacuations of persons wishing to leave
combat zones this is vital a vital form
of assistance
to the almost 18 million people in need
of humanitarian assistance in ukraine
the situation the situation in mario
paul to mention just this town is
becoming plainly untenable the
exponential deterioration in living
conditions indeed survival conditions in
certain places is very concerning
especially when civilian infrastructure
and the provision of essential
public services are affected is affected
we are concerned at the risks of disease
resulting from water shortages in
certain parts of ukraine but also health
risks ensuing from the lack of access to
primary or specialized health care
women
children
the elderly and anyone
not taking part in hostilities should be
able to be rescued in every sense of the
word
without fearing for their lives madam
president
war is a horror
a break
with
that which binds us together as humans
it is precisely to seek to reduce the
effects of this break that international
humanitarian law exists
to not give free rein to the expression
of might is right in fact it is an
attempt to address through law a break
in the human contract all parties should
abide by international humanitarian law
concerning the persistent reports of
massacres
summary executions atrocities and other
mass crimes against civilians in butcher
there is an urgent need for a un-led
free and independent inquiry
into
as soon as possible to shed light on the
victims and the circumstances
surrounding these atrocities in the
interim it is vital that this council
not lose sight of its role which is to
work towards restoring peace and
security by offering an alternative to
war the return
to peace in ukraine will not be achieved
through mudslinging
madam president this war has lasted long
enough and its effects are already being
felt
felt beyond ukraine's borders from our
perspective
the equation is posed in terms of a
decision on establishing a ceasefire and
on creating the conditions for safe and
unfitted provision of humanitarian
assistance needed by populations in
distress
i wish to reiterate gabon's appreciation
to
neighboring countries that continue to
mobilize to
urgently welcome refugees we encourage
them to extend the same welcome to all
persons in distress without distinction
as to origin or race including african
nationals and students
we request
them to ensure respect for their dignity
and we call for fair treatment of all
persons in distress it is urgent that
the parties commit resolutely
to
negotiation to bring an end to the
hostilities we call
to a de escalation and a
halt to the combat
there is no other way my country is
closely following current negotiations
between the parties especially in
istanbul
and we hope that they will soon lead to
a ceasefire so as to create a climate of
confidence and to establish the climate
of calm needed for diplomacy to make its
voice heard and for the guns to be
silenced thank you
i thank the representative of gabon for
her statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of the russian
federation
thank you madam president
i would like to first of all
express your
gratitude to the
delegation of the united arab emirates
for their presidency in the month of
march we're also grateful to the
secretary general to rosemary dicarlo
and martin griffith
for their briefings
we also listen to the president of
ukraine vladimir zelinsky
we'd like to thank martin for his visit
to moscow
during which as far as we can judge
he had some useful meetings and
discussions
better than anyone else he should know
the efforts that russia is undertaking
every single day to organize
humanitarian corridors
however
the arrangements reached with the help
of
international mediators
is consistently not being
implemented by the ukrainian side
i'm not going to
overload you with figures you can
such communiques are published every
single day by our ministry of defense i
simply would like to say that just out
of my opal toward the east
without any participation by the
ukrainian side we have managed to save
123 and a half thousand people
now overall since the beginning of the
special military operation
over 600
000 people have been evacuated to russia
including over and nineteen thousand
children and we're not talking about any
kind of coercion or abduction as
our western partners like to
present this but rather the voluntary
decision by these people
is testified by many uh videos that are
accessible in social media
madam president
another topic of the meeting was
declared today which
is practically not being discussed today
so i'm going to uh leave that out i
simply would like to
take advantage of the virtual presence
here of the
president of ukraine and would like to
address him directly
now we place on your conscience
the uh un
grounded accusations against the russian
military which are not confirmed by any
uh
any eyewitnesses and we spoke about this
in detail yesterday at our press
conference
vladimir alexander rich we all remember
when in 2019 you were elected as the
president of the ukraine
now there were a lot of hopes uh tied to
your election because
you uh
you
were as a candidate to pledge peace and
an end to the warren donbass
including the russian-speaking
population which you pledged to protect
so it seemed that we were on the verge
of correcting the historical injustice
when as a result of the maidan
coup in 2014
uh
ukraine began to be transformed into a
hateful anti-russia and that seemed to
be on the verge of being turned
that page of being
turned
however
those hopes uh failed to be
to materialize and now you scornfully
call the
the residents of donetsk and lugansk
people's republic as a subspecies
repeating what your predecessor
uh stated who in fact threatened that
the residents of the donetsk and lugansk
will rot in their basements
and you are calling on them to return to
leave to leave and to russia
and now you've declared war against your
native russian language
by introducing in essence a linguistic
inquisition and a country where russian
is the native language for a minimum 40
percent of the population
and today explosions and artillery
rounds are exploding
over the entire territory of ukraine and
not only in the east where they haven't
ceased for the past eight years
and they're exploding precisely because
there was no other way of bringing peace
to the donbass unfortunately
after you and your subordinates
categorically refused to comply with the
minsk agreements at the same time by
preparing already back in march to solve
the problem of the donbass by military
means in the course of our special
operations we have found many secret
orders testifying to this
we're told
that there can be no nazis
in ukraine however we know very well
that not only are they there but
unfortunately they are running the show
and how can it be uh any other way when
the national heroes of ukraine are nazi
collaborators bandera and shuhaevich who
are responsible not only for the
holocaust but the killing of hundreds of
thousands of peaceful polls russians
ukrainians and jews
you simply preferred not to notice
ukrainian nazis
uh pretending that they're simply not
there but unfortunately they are there
and
uh they they are very many of them and
among them a lot of young people
how do we know that well they're not
concealing it they have tattoos made
nazi tattoos they decorate their uh
their clothing with swastikas and other
nazi symbols they greet each they give
nazi greetings and they're open about it
in the social media
they're
they're particularly many of them in the
national battalion such as idah the
right sector and the assa of battalion
and that would be one thing but they are
also acting like nazis and they're
killing like them
and they're not just killing
russia russian or prisoner soldiers on
which they torture and gloat about it on
the social media but they kill their own
your neo-nazis and radicals are
have shown unrivaled cruelty against the
civilians which they use as human
shields and
position
position heavy artillery next to
residential buildings and multiple
rocket launchers as well today we've
heard once again a huge amount of lies
about russian
soldiers and military
we have hundreds if not thousands of
video testimonials of people who are
ready to provide testimony about the
cruelty of ukrainian nationals i'll just
read some of them here
these are cruel histories but you need
to hear them
natalia kudinova says the mayor of the
town
was one of the first to run away
afterwards the ukrainian
authorities lied that russia was not
letting people through humanitarian
corridors
the national battalion as of under
threat of death kept women and children
in basements and it robbed civilians at
checkpoints
a graham mother
said that the asset battalion did not
allow her to leave
basements anyone trying to leave was
shot at the as of checkpoint
women and chill and girls were stripped
naked and had their jewelry and money
taken away
including their
valentin
nikolevna borisenka
says how ukrainian uh soldiers kicked
out
women with two children from a private
home and then used it to lob mortar
rounds
and that women had two children she was
they were kicked out uh
by soldiers with blue armbands those are
ukrainian insignias
insignias of the ukrainian army marina
vasily even uh
testified that she was tortured in a
basement by ukrainian security services
they tied me to a sewer pipe when i
found out i was russian they beat me
used electric current raped me and they
threatened to rape my young daughter
shapovalova olga gear given and we left
mariupol from
magusha on the 25th of march
firing positions of the ukrainian army
were positioned between residential
homes and in the courtyard of a school
they use civilians as cover and the
neighborhood around the drama theater
a ukrainian tank drove around firing
indiscriminately including targeting
residential buildings on the territory
the
68th and the fifth school tanks were
stationed i saw this with my own eyes
madame suportkina olga gave now this is
her testimony and school number 15 of
marubo from starting from 25th of
february
the ukrainian armed forces took up
positions and left on the 7th of march
they directed fire from there our
building was badly damaged from the
shelling on the 8th and 9th of march
there were intense shelling
intentionally targeting residential
homes ukrainian soldiers were asked why
they're doing it they replied that until
they destroyed the entire russian spirit
in whole they will remain there
they started looting immediately they
plundered all the shops
and it was the uh forces of the dundas
people's republic that helped evacuate
us and drove us to mangusha there are
many other heart-rending stories
there are uh russians and ukrainians
tortured to death with uh swastikas
burned into their uh chests there are uh
uh looters and and uh uh criminals who
who
you distributed weapons to there's
civilians and and foreigners
who are held hostages and in spite of
all factual evidence and common sense
you're trying to lay the blame for their
death on the russian military this is
absolutely unacceptable the fact that
even consider that russian
military would be capable of this and
now we're seeing
blatant criminally staged events with
the
ukrainian civilians who are killed by
their own radicals in the best
traditions of gables to accuse the
russian army
those killed in the areas from which the
russian forces withdrew after
encouraging
peace negotiations in istanbul
so now it turns out that we shouldn't
have withdrawn i'm talking about butcher
first and foremost i understand that
you uh were shown you saw corpses and
heard testimonials but you only saw what
they showed you you couldn't ignore the
flagrant inconsistencies in the version
of events which are being promoted by
ukrainian and western media
the fact that the corpses were not there
right after the withdrawal of the uh
russian forces which is confirmed by
several videos and the fact that they're
recordings where ukrainian radicals urge
shooting at those with white armbands in
other words against civilians
if you saw the the video very carefully
that was shown today you'll see that
those people who are on the ground have
white
armbands these are civilians
and the fact that the corpses on the
video in no way resemble those that
could have been lying on the street for
three or four days and based on the
sensational and completely
scientifically absurd information of the
new york times they were there since the
20th of march
so the only ones who could fall for this
fake are absolute diligence or
western partners who don't want to hear
anything and have have been calling
black white and vice versa for a long
time now
unfortunately
these countries don't give a hoot about
ukraine itself
it's simply a pawn in the in the
geopolitical game against russia which
they will sacrifice easily but in the
meantime they will try to prolong the
conflict
by delivering as much weapons as
possible and ammunition but the most
important thing is that
how have we sunk to such depths of
cruelty that nationalists are uh
displaying for example those from the as
of battalion and you i'm i'm addressing
the ukrainian president
in your interview with the americans
media you coyly bashfully state that
they are what they are
i really hope that you will reflect
on this and hope that you will find a
solution to the situation because it
depends only on you because
we came to you to ukraine not to conquer
lands we came to bring the long-awaited
peace to the blood-soaked land of
donbass not a truce
but a true lasting peace and for this we
need to root out the cruelty which i
mentioned we need to cut out the
malignant nazi tumor that is consuming
ukraine and would in time begin to
consume russia and we will achieve that
goal i hope sooner rather than later
because there is no other outcome
we are not shooting against
civilian targets in order to save as
many civilians as possible this is
precisely why we're not advancing as
fast as many expected
we're not acting like americans and
their allies in iraq and syria were
raising entire cities to the ground they
had no pity for them but we felt great
pity because these are people who are
close to us
but radicals have nothing to lose they
couldn't care less about civilians
they're ready to take to the grave with
them the entire population of the
ukraine as was clearly demonstrated by
the provocation in bucha don't allow the
west to achieve its goals vladimir
alexandrovich
make the right decisions that are needed
for your country because the west is
ready to fight in the ukraine until the
last ukrainian take make that decision
now because the real you know the real
situation on the front
later
it might be too late soon thank you very
much for your attention
i thank the representative of the
russian federation for his statement and
i now give the floor to the
representative of ireland
thank you very much madam president and
i'd also like to thank the secretary
general and our other briefers this
morning
i want to express a very warm welcome to
president zielenski being with us this
morning president zielenski your courage
your leadership and the courage of the
ukrainian people
are an example to all of us
secretary general on the 24th of
february as russia launched a
large-scale invasion of its neighbor
ukraine you told the world that russia's
action was wrong
that it was against the charter that it
was unacceptable
we agreed with you however you also told
us
that this invasion was reversible
and called on president putin to end
this war to save innocent lives
we echoed those calls
sadly 40 days later
our call has been left unanswered
instead
over the last 40 days
we have witnessed unprecedented levels
of destruction
and human suffering
we are watching cities pounded by
russian artillery we are seeing millions
forced to flee their homes
seeking refuge from russian aggression
just minutes ago here in this chamber we
have seen the utterly shocking images
of civilians lying
dead in the streets of butcher and
elsewhere in ukraine some we know are
piled into improvised mass graves
simply harrowing
so many innocent lives lost on our watch
as our pleas for peace go unheeded
the attempts here today
to deny russian culpability are frankly
appalling in their cynicism
and i see them as an insult to the
memory of those slaughtered civilians
madam president we roundly condemn the
atrocities reportedly committed by the
russian armed forces in a number of
occupied ukrainian towns
the images from bucha and other towns in
the kiev region liberated by ukrainian
forces
are horrifying
we here cannot suspend our humanity
our thoughts first and foremost must be
with the families of those killed
their pain at the loss of their loved
ones in such an unspeakable manner
is almost unimaginable
let's be clear
the russian authorities are responsible
for these atrocities committed while
they had effective control of the area
the russian authorities are subject to
the international law of occupation
there can never be impunity from such
crimes
never ever
not in bucha not another any other town
or village ever
for crimes have been committed they must
be fully investigated and evidence
preserved so that these crimes can be
prosecuted by domestic and international
courts including the international
criminal court
ireland will continue to support efforts
to ensure robust and independent
investigation of all violations of
international law
we must have accountability and justice
for the victims and for the survivors of
this war
we at this table share that
responsibility in face of such atrocity
we call on the russian federation to
abide by the order of the international
court of justice and to immediately
cease its military action and withdraw
from the entire territory of ukraine
madam president in the last 40 days we
have seen a horrific humanitarian
disaster
unfold in ukraine because of the russian
federation's unprovoked and
unjustifiable further invasion of that
country
a country where just weeks ago citizens
lived in relative peace and prosperity
and one which has been transformed now
into one where families lack access to
basic necessities
where basements have become bob shelters
where millions millions have become idps
and refugees
the use of explosive weapons in
populated areas has had a devastating
impact on civilians in the midst of
active hostilities
once again we call for the parties to
the conflict to comply with
international humanitarian law
including the obligation to direct
attacks only against military objectives
the prohibitions against indiscriminate
and disproportionate attacks and the
obligation to take all feasible
precautions in attack
we have heard increasing allegations of
sexual violence by russian soldiers
you referred to this this morning
secretary general
we must stress that conflict-related
sexual violence can constitute a war
crime
the perpetrators of such crimes must be
accountable
they must be held accountable they will
be held accountable
sexual violence is another abhorrent
crime of this war that cannot go
unanswered
we again reiterate the need for full
safe and unhindered humanitarian access
to those in need as called for today by
martin griffiths
secretary general we again echo your
call for russia to implement an
immediate humanitarian ceasefire
it is the very least the aggressor can
do it is way past time
as we know
the reverberations of this war are
reaching far beyond ukraine
it's unacceptable that russia's war of
choice against ukraine is also having
and will continue to have significant
spillover effects across the globe
deterioration of food security surging
energy prices
increasing poverty
the most vulnerable and impoverished in
developing countries will suffer the
most
we utterly reject that
madam president it is our collective
responsibility here at this table to
maintain international peace and
security
nothing less
this is why we call on the russian
federation to stop this war
to stop its unlawful attempts to
establish
occupying authorities to stop
destabilizing
the democratic foundations of the
ukrainian state
such steps are yet further reprehensible
violations of ukraine's independence
sovereignty and territorial integrity
it gets harder each time to say this but
it is never too late to do the right
thing and to end this war now thank you
madam president
i thank the representative of ireland
for her statement and i now give the
floor to the representative of brazil
thank you madam president
let me start by thanking ambassador
nusebe
along with her team at the uae mission
for
competently navigating the work of the
security council in march
i welcome his excellency mr vladimir
zelinsky president of ukraine
in the council today
i would like to thank the secretary
general antonio guterres
secretary general for political affairs
rosemary dicarlo and i'm the secretary
general for humanitarian affairs martin
griffiths
for their updated presentations about
the situation in
ukraine madam president
as we enter into the sixth week of
hostilities in the ukrainian territory
we continue to witness appalling images
of human suffering
the recent reports of acts of violence
against civilians
in bucha erpin kharkiv donetsk and other
places affected by the conflict are
extremely worrying
according to the statement by the icrc
we call for a really independent and
thorough investigation
of all reported violations
with the full cooperation of both
parties to the conflict
without prejudging any conclusions
and underscore the need for perpetrators
to be held accountable
the international community is
witnessing for too long appalling scenes
of destruction of once peaceful cities
with shocking images from the conflict
and the desperation of thousands of
civilians trapped in the battlefield
with no food
no water and no electricity
once again
we renew our players for a broad
effective and immediate cessation of
hostilities in ukraine
only after the silence of the guns and
the withdrawal of troops
are achieved will it be possible to halt
the immense costs of human suffering
this conflict has brought
madam president
the general assembly has recently
adopted a resolution
on the humanitarian situation in ukraine
as we said on that occasion
the general assembly could not become a
bystander of the shocking consequences
of the conflict
and
as we added last week in this chamber
neither
can the security council
has the main u.n organ with primary
responsibility
for the maintenance of international
peace and security
the security council has the mandate
and the responsibility
to address this situation in an
effective manner
nevertheless
our assessment is that the security
council is failing in its role to help
in supporting efforts to foster a
constructive dialogue between the
parties
with the aim of brokering an effective
peer settlement
to this conflict
we deeply regret that the security
council has not been able to speak with
one voice throughout the crisis
compliance with international
humanitarian law
protecting civilians calling for peace
these are objectives that should unite
rather than divide us
we should strive to create the
conditions for
on the one hand
invigorating the political negotiations
and on the other
reaching an understanding on practical
measures to minimize human suffering in
ukraine
civilians wishing to flee the
hostilities
must be able to do so in safety
and those who decide to stay
cannot become targets of attacks
in the same vein
parties must grant safe passage to
relief consignments to those in need
once again brazil reiterates the call
for all parties to fully respect and
ensure respect for international
humanitarian law
the causes of conflict whatever they are
do not undermine the obligations of all
parties
have to guarantee that civilians should
be protected that the wounded receive
medical care
that humanitarian assistance reach those
in need
and that detainees be treated humanely
in all circumstances
there must be no politicization of
humanitarian actions
nor selective application of
international humanitarian law
also
geopolitical objectives must not
supersede the endeavor for peace nor
prolong the human suffering
caused by war
madam president
this conflict and its associated
sanctions
apart from the enormous human suffering
and devastation
caused in ukraine
is having spillover effects in the
entire world
especially through increased prices of
oil gas grains and fertilizers among
others
food insecurity has become an even
greater threat to the world's poorest
people
above all in developing countries
the longer this conflict persists
the higher the risk of further
instability hunger and devastation in
ukraine
and around the world
it is high time
to return to the path of dialogue and
diplomacy
for a peaceful settlement of the
conflict
we urgently need the cessation of
hostilities
de-escalation of tensions and
negotiations are the only way out of
this conflict
not only for the countries directly
involved but also for the entire world i
thank you madam president
i thank the representative of brazil for
his remarks and i now give the floor to
the representative of kenya
thank you madam president
i congratulate you on assuming the
presidency of the security council for
april and assure you of my delegation's
full support
i listened closely to the remarks by the
secretary general and his under
secretaries general rosemary dicarlo and
martin griffiths
hoping to hear that our fears that the
war in ukraine has entered a new
more dangerous phase were exaggerated
sadly they offered no such comfort
instead we are left with the words of
his excellency volodmir zelensky the
president of ukraine
who has described the horrifying
suffering of civilians in butcher and
other towns and neighborhoods in ukraine
his account of the atrocities
is in stark contrast to that of our
colleague in the security council the
representative of the russian federation
but the fact that the truth in butcher
is contested
is the surest sign that we stand on the
precipice of more widespread abuses of
human rights
in april 1994
even as genocide engulfed rwanda
there were members of the security
council contesting the horrifying truth
that a million people were being
murdered
we should stand warned that the
inability of the council
to establish the facts
and accordingly attribute responsibility
may enable the risk of escalation into
far worse crimes
beyond the city of butcher madam
president we're extremely worried about
the safety of civilians who are trapped
in other besieged cities and villages
such as mario paul
and queson
our actions today should seek to prevent
what we have witnessed happen in butcher
take place
in mario paul and queson
while we debate who is responsible for
the horrors of butcher
it is incontestable that what started as
a special military operation
is now a war
and that what began with reassurances of
limited aims
not targeted at civilians has led to
thousands of dead civilians and millions
of refugees and internally displaced
no one can doubt that they are flagrant
violations of international law
international humanitarian law and the
u.n charter underway in ukraine
kenya condemns the abuses undertaken in
the past few weeks
and those in the eastern provinces of
the country during the years that the
conflict has raged
madam president
the war in ukraine is today's most
dangerous threat to the maintenance of
international peace and security
it is the latest assault
by the most powerful states against the
multilateral order
their continued abuse of the charter
created growing cracks over the years
in the global security order
now the bottom has fallen out
ukraine may now become a model for new
generation of disastrous wars on
multiple continents
millions of refugees are being created
and there will be many more as the
economic effects of the war produce and
intensify conflicts elsewhere
accelerating food and energy prices
are plunging millions into worse forms
of poverty
the u.n as a forum for solutions to
humanity's most pressing problems
is losing prestige and its historical
standing
president zielinski has left us with
ideas for security council reform that
we need to consider seriously
things have fallen apart and the center
cannot hold under these assaults on our
united nations we must reform
there are no easy solutions
even a negotiation
that is not properly structured to
protect the people and sovereignty of
ukraine could be the prelude to a wider
war
for now we urge the following urgent
steps understanding their limits due to
the continued inability of the security
council to act decisively
we call for an impartial and prompt
united nations investigation
into the atrocities against the
civilians in butcher and other towns in
ukraine
this calls for an immediate end of all
hostilities to guarantee unfettered
access by the investigating teams
we urge the conflicting parties to
immediately make clear to their military
personnel
that they will be held to account on the
basis of command or superior
responsibility if they violate the
international laws that regulate warfare
we commend ukraine's neighbors for
opening their borders to refugees of
multiple nationalities from ukraine
we continue to urge them to ensure that
the thousands of affected africans be
treated in accordance with international
humanitarian law and basic dignity
we commend ocha and many other
organizations and individuals who have
come to the aid of the deserving people
of ukraine
in this regard we welcome the third
un-organized humanitarian convoy that
reached thousands of people in need in
sumi and other cities
we call for the urgent activation of
safe
passages with no restrictions and call
for unimpeded humanitarian access to the
many in need particularly those in mario
paul kason and other besieged cities
we also urge
the security council to reassure the
world of its relevance by approaching
the other conflicts with renewed vigor
the humanitarian crisis caused by
conflict in afghanistan in haiti the
horn of africa the unfolding situation
in the korean peninsula lebanon libya
myanmar palestine and israel syria yemen
and the sahel deserve our urgent
attention
we look forward to the secretary general
rallying the international community to
deploy resources to cushion the most
vulnerable from the effects of the
conflict in ukraine
we reiterate our call for the cessation
of hostilities to allow humanitarian
operations under clearly defined contact
lines
and humanitarian passages
madam president i finish by reaffirming
kenya's recognition of the inviolable
rights of ukraine to its sovereignty
territorial integrity and political
independence i thank you
i thank the representative of kenya for
his statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of mexico
madam president
we wish
you every success during your presidency
this month
and we
recognize and acknowledge
the work of the united arab
emirates in leading the work of the
security council last month
we thank the secretary general
and under secretaries general de carlo
and griffiths for their briefings
and we appreciate the participation of
president
val vladimir zelinsky
in this meeting of the security council
we have listened to him
we did so closely
and with
the respect due
his office we have also looked on
with horror at the images shared with us
they are like the grenica mural
recrea recreated with even more civilian
victims
for the past six weeks
the world has been looking on in this
may at the devastating consequences of
russia's invasion of ukraine
through two general assembly resolutions
the international community has taken a
clear and strong stance
by deploring that invasion and
demanding an immediate cessation of
hostilities and any attack against
civilian populations or
civilian infrastructure
and it has also pointed to the urgent
need for secure
and unfettered
swift humanitarian access
the international court of justice also
ordered the immediate suspension of
military operations on ukrainian
territory
it now falls to the united nations
to take action in as much as it is the
guarantor of the
enforcement of the icj's
decisions all mechanisms for peaceful
settlement of dispute
established under international law must
be geared towards a check achieving this
common objective regrettably
hostilities continue and their impact on
civilians is worsening as are the
humanitarian needs of the population
including
the humanitarian needs of
more and more
more and more urgent need of refugees
and internally displaced persons
the flood of images of the streets of
bucha and other cities circulating in
recent days have moved the world
we
strongly condemn the atrocities captured
in those images
there is absolutely nothing that can
justify them
protecting the civilian population
is
an undeniable responsibility born by the
international community
as the high commissioner for human
rights pointed out
gross
international humanitarian and
international human human rights law
violations compel us
to consider the possibility that
war crimes may indeed have been
committed
mexico stands
strongly and resolutely by the secretary
general's statement calling for prompt
impartial investigations leading to the
identification of perpetrators and
effective accountability for them
by the same token we will be closely
following the work of the international
criminal court
and we support the prosecutor
who is now in the process of
investigating allegations of
international crimes committed in
ukraine
as well as the independent international
commission of inquiry established for
the same person by the united nations
human rights council and their reports
will be decisive
the consequences of this war have been
horrifying
its
tragic impact will produce
serious
effects
in the medium and long term not only in
the region but throughout the rest of
the world as was clearly stated by the
executive director of the world food
program
millions of people
will
pay
themselves the toll
in this conflict
supplies of basic food items will run
short in many regions where they are
already insecure and fragile
now given all the difficulties
that this implies
and the urgency ensuing the efforts of
the community international community to
tackle the humanitarian tragedy are only
temporary the solution as it has been
said
is an immediate end to the hostilities
and a political agreement that restores
diplomatic negotiations
we are resolutely resolutely in support
of under secretary general griffith's
initiatives to broker humanitarian
pauses
to pave the way for
smoother delivery of humanitarian
assistance mexico appreciates and
commends the work of all humanitarian
actors involved in ukraine
as well as the solidarity of neighboring
countries that have received millions of
refugees
and the mediation efforts of various
actors and countries
it is our hope that this council
will fulfill its responsibility to
contribute effectively to putting an end
to the war and restoring peace and to do
so in strict compliance with
international law
and international
humanitarian law
and put an end to war and restore peace
thank
you i thank the representative of mexico
for his statement and i now give the
floor to the representative of india
thank you madam president
let me begin by thanking secretary
general antonio gutierrez
for his presence and remarks on the
situation in ukraine i also thank usg
rosemary de carlo and usd martin
griffiths for their respective briefings
on the security and humanitarian
situation
we thank the participation of the
excellency the president of ukraine at
today's meeting
i also take this opportunity to thank
the united arab emirates and ambassador
lana nusaiba for their excellent
presidency
madam president the situation in ukraine
has not shown any significant
improvement since the council last
discussed the issue
the security situation has only
deteriorated as well as its humanitarian
consequences
recent reports of civilian killings in
bhusha are deeply disturbing
we unequivocally condemn these killings
and support the call for an independent
investigation
we hope the international community will
continue to respond positively to the
humanitarian needs
we support calls urging for guarantees
of safe passage to deliver essential
humanitarian and medical supplies
keeping in view the dire humanitarian
situation in ukraine india has been
sending humanitarian supplies to ukraine
and its neighbors which include
medicines and other essential relief
material
we stand ready to provide more medical
supplies to ukraine in the coming days
india continues to remain deeply
concerned at the worsening situation and
reiterates its call for immediate
secession of violence and end to
hostilities
we have emphasized right from the
beginning of the conflict the need to
pursue the path of diplomacy and
dialogue
when innocent human lives are at stake
diplomacy must prevail as the only
viable option
in this context
we take note of the ongoing efforts
including the meetings held recently
between the parties
the impact of the crisis is being felt
beyond the region with increasing food
and energy costs especially for many
developing countries
it is in our collective interest to work
constructively both inside the united
nations and outside towards seeking an
early resolution to the conflict
allow me to reiterate the importance of
human guiding principles humanitarian
assistance once again
humanitarian action must always be
guided by the principles of humanitarian
assistance just humanity neutrality
impartiality and independence
these measures should never be
politicized
we continue to emphasize to all member
states of the u.n that the global order
is anchored on international law un
charter and respect for territorial
integrity and sovereignty of states i
thank you madam president
i thank the representative of india for
his statement
and i now give the floor to the
representative of china
thank you madam president madam
president
i first of all would like to
congratulate you
upon assuming the presidency of the
council for this month at the same time
i would also like to thank ambassador
nuzepe as well as the uae team for their
outstanding work when
uae was the president of the council
during the month of march
madam president de-escalating tension in
ukraine and putting an early end to the
fighting is the urgent expectation of
the international community and the
strong desire of china we have many
times emphasized that dialogue and
negotiation is the only way out for
opening a door of peace
russia and ukraine have already had
many rounds of negotiations we welcome
the two sides to stick to the general
direction of
peace negotiations overcome difficulties
and differences and continue to build
conditions for a comprehensive
settlement of the crisis
the international community should
create
favorable conditions and environment for
negotiations between the two sides open
up space for political settlement and
should not set up roadblocks to increase
resistance for peace let alone add fuel
to the fire to aggravate confrontations
every effort should be made to prevent
the escalation of the localized conflict
china attaches great importance to the
humanitarian issue in ukraine and
supports all initiatives and measures
conducive to alleviate the humanitarian
crisis in ukraine as the current
conflict continues we call on the
parties to abide by international
humanitarian law protect the safety of
civilians and civilian facilities
minimize civilian casualties
and ensure safe and smooth evacuation
and access of humanitarian corridors
as well as
the basic rights of women children and
wounded fighters
humanitarian issues should not be
politicized the humanitarian needs of
ukraine and its neighboring countries
are enormous international humanitarian
agencies should maintain neutral
uh and impartial
uh should maintain neutrality and
impartiality actively mobilize and
coordinate more resources and make
unremitting efforts to save lives and
protect civilians china has provided and
will continue to provide humanitarian
assistance to ukraine and its
neighboring countries under
international law civilians should be
spared of any forms of violence in armed
conflict and attacks against civilians
are unacceptable and should not occur
the reports and images of civilian
deaths in bucharest are very disturbing
and the relevant circumstances and
specific causes of the incident must be
verified and established
any and all acquisitions should be based
on facts before conclusions are drawn
parties should exercise restraint and
avoid unfunded acquisitions
madam president
as
pointed out by secretary general
guterres the spilled over effects of the
ukrainian crisis is having a major
impact on the world and the developing
countries in particular
this requires our great attention
and our strengthened management
sanctions are not an effective means to
solve the problem but will instead
accelerate the spillover of the crisis
and bring new and complex problems
today
with the deep development of
globalization and the closely linked
community of mankind the implementation
of all dimensional and indiscriminate
sanctions is tantamount to politicizing
instrumentalizing and weaponizing the
world economy triggering serious crisis
in the fields of global economy and
trade finance energy food industrial
chain and supply chain
and endangering decades of development
gains of the international community and
making people of all countries pay a
hefty price
the vast number of development countries
are not purchased to the conflict and
should not be involved in this
confrontation let alone be forced to
bear the consequences of geopolitical
conflicts and great power competition
the world's major economists should be
responsible for managing the risk of
crisis spilled over and maintaining the
stability of global markets and the
momentum of the global economic recovery
madam president
more than 30 years after the end of the
cold war
such a due political tragedy taking
place of in europe now deserves our
profound reflection the sovereignty and
territory integrity of all countries
should be respected and small and
medium-sized countries should not be
pushed to the forefront of confrontation
between an among great powers all
countries have the right to decide their
foreign policy independently and should
not be forced to take sides the security
of all countries is inseparable and the
security of one country cannot be
achieved at the expense of the security
of others we call upon the united states
nato and the european union to engage in
comprehensive dialogues with russia to
face head on their differences
accumulated over the years find
solutions to the problem and promote the
building of a balanced effective and
sustainable regional security framework
on the issue of ukraine china does not
seek geopolitical self-interest it is
not our mindset to watch the situation
indifferently from the sideline let
alone do anything to add fuel to the
fire there's only one goal we sincerely
look forward to and that is peace china
will continue to promote peace talks and
play a constructive and responsible role
in helping resolve the crisis in ukraine
i thank you madam president
i thank the representative of china for
his statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of france
president
like to hail the participation of
president zelinski this meeting and
through him i'd like to hail the courage
and the spirit of resistance of the
ukrainian people
uh
france stands by your side i thank the
secretary general the under secretary
general for political affairs and the
under secretary general for humanitarian
affairs for their statements
the war of aggression that russia is
conducting against ukraine has in the
past few days reached a new threshold of
horror
the images of mass graves
and of mass atrocities against civilians
in towns in the north of ukraine in
bucharest
have
led to the condemnation and indignation
around the world we like to express our
wholehearted compassion for victims and
our
full solidarity with the ukrainians and
we're still shocked by the horrific
images that
were shown in the video this morning
france condemns in the strongest terms
the massive atrocities committed by the
russian forces these
atrocities could constitute war crimes
but also crimes against humanity
the disinformation tactics used by
russia to conceal its crimes
unfortunately are no surprise to anyone
once again moscow
to the
disgrace of the murder of civilians and
children is adding the disgrace of
lying and denial madam president in the
face of these horrific crimes france
urges not giving into hatred and rather
to take action along the following lines
first of all we need to maintain the
strongest possible pressure to compel
the russian authorities to put an end to
a war that is compromising global
security
and
well beyond europe including food
security
france is fully engaged to contribute to
this in particular with its european
partners in the framework of the french
presidency of the european
council and the g7 it will continue its
determined support to the ukrainian
authorities in all possible forms
secondly the crimes committed in ukraine
should not remain unpunished credible
independent
uh inquiries should be conducted to
allow national and international
jurisdictions that
have competence to judge the
perpetrators of these atrocities in
particular we call on russia as well as
ukraine to fully cooperate with the
international criminal court and with
the commission of inquiries set up by
the human rights council madam president
russia
is
pursuing methodically and with
determination it's war of ukraine with
its share of destruction and tragedy
we call for the respect of international
humanitarian law civilians including
children and humanitarian personnel must
be protected
the same goes for civilian
infrastructure in particular hospitals
and schools we
we welcome the mobilization of the
countries neighboring ukraine who are
playing a major role in
in receiving refugees a hospitality that
they've demonstrated as a credit to
europe the european union has in
particular mobilized a package of over
500 million
euros of urgent support to the ukraine
and the european council that took place
on the 24th and 25th of march also has
planned to set up a uh
a trust fund of solidarity for the
ukraine france has also contributed 100
million of humanitarian assistance we
support the efforts of secretary general
and martin griffith to achieve a
humanitarian ceasefire to allow the
evacuation of civilians from besieged
cities and to ensure access of
humanitarian assistance all efforts
should be made in order to achieve a
cessation of hostilities this is a an
initial stage towards a lasting solution
of the conflict and it's necessary for
the credibility
of the russian
involvement in negotiations france is
determined to continue to contribute to
efforts of peace in particular by by
supporting ukrainian authorities in
seeking a political solution once the
ceasefire is achieved as well as by
maintaining channels of dialogue with
russia madam president
as
uh the french minister of europe and
foreign affairs recalled on the third of
april
france is fully engaged in putting end
to this war of aggression
of which the human cost and humanitarian
impact is increasing by the day in the
face of the horror of the russian
aggression france reaffirms its
solidarity and support for the ukraine
and ukrainian people we also call on the
russian people who are also victims in
this war to continue to find ways of
expressing their opposition to this
conflict in spite of the repression this
is necessary to break the logic of
hatred in which vladimir putin wants to
imprison both ukrainians and russians
thank you very much
i thank the representative of france for
her statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of norway
thank you president
i thank the briefers for their valuable
inputs
norway
also express its ultimate support to you
secretary general to make full use of
your good offices in search for a
peaceful solution
i want to thank president zielenski
through you ambassador
for his strong testimony this morning
and for the heroic fight
the president the ukrainian government
and the ukrainian people are engaged in
for your country and for the peace and
freedom of us all
we are with you and we support you
as we heard from president zielenski and
have seen this weekend the need for
peace could not be more urgent
for more than 40 days and nights attacks
from russia have continued to batter the
ukrainian people
and their cities
causing death and destruction
and the suffering is escalating
we too are appalled by the reports
coming out of the areas around kiev and
other regions
we are deeply shocked by the atrocities
committed against civilians in places
that has been held by the russian forces
including butcher the images are
distressing
dead bodies on the roads and in mass
graves
homes school hospitals and other
civilian infrastructure destroyed
and reportedly left mind
president
russia is desperate to hide the truth
about the war but us atrocities must be
investigated and those responsible must
be brought to justice
in this respect we welcome the
establishment by the human rights
council of a commission of inquiry on
ukraine
to investigate all alleged violation of
international humanitarian law
and human rights law and we also welcome
that the icc has opened an investigation
into the situation in ukraine
we urge russia and everyone holding
evidence to fully cooperate with these
investigations
we cannot allow there to be impunity for
war crimes being committed in ukraine
the world is watching
president
russia's unprovoked an illegal war
against ukraine a free and sovereign
country is also an attack on democratic
values and on freedom
it is a blatant violation of
international law and the very
principles of the u.n charter and as the
secretary general on the line this
morning this council has a
responsibility we must do everything in
our power to end the war and to mitigate
its impact
let me repeat the message by the
norwegian prime minister sturridge gave
to president putin when he spoke when
they spoke on thursday
he urged him to seize the hostilities
and emphasize that russia must ensure
rapid safe and unimpeded humanitarian
access to the civilian population
particularly in mario pool he stressed
also the need to find a negotiated
solution to end the war
president the suffering is widespread
russia's war is causing the largest
humanitarian crisis in europe since the
second world war
a quarter of the ukrainian population
has now been displaced
and cluster munition will continue to
maim and kill long after the conflict
has ended
the reconstruction
when it comes will take years
ukraine has been set back decades in its
economic development
and the consequences of this war will be
felt by generation of ukrainians
russia's war is also being felt globally
exacerbating other humanitarian crises
and causing a serious negative effect on
the agricultural sector with a global
rise in food ensue insecurity and
increased prices of fuel and fertilizers
president before concluded concluding
let me be very clear much
russia must abide by international law
it must comply with the order of the
international court of justice to
immediately suspend this military
operation and to withdraw its troop from
ukraine
the killing and destruction must end
russia must stop its illegal war thank
you
representative of norway for her
statement and i now give the floor to
the representative of ghana
thank you very much madam president i
congratulate the uae for its successful
presidency in the preceding month and
wish you
and the uk delegation the very best for
this month
let me begin by thanking secretary
general the secretary general for his
statement to the council
and welcoming the briefings of usg
rosemary dicarlo
and usg and emergency relief coordinator
martin griffins
on the prevailing situation ukraine and
the coordinated humanitarian response
of the united nations agencies
in the face of difficult operational
challenges on the ground
i also welcome the virtual participation
in this meeting of the president of
ukraine his excellency
mr
vladimir zelinsky
my delegation has taken careful notes of
the ukrainian president's remark
noted his country's steadfast commitment
to peace
and encouraged the path of dialogue and
diplomacy in finding a settlement of
this needless war
madame president the prolongation of the
war in ukraine continues to be a
situation of deep concern for ghana
we are particularly disturbed by the
increasing humanitarian cost arising
from the unjustified
aggression by the russian federation
against ukraine
we have observed repaint and bridled
bombardment
of civilian populated areas as well as
civilian and other critical
infrastructure
without regard to the customary norms of
international law and the principles of
international humanitarian law
relating to armed conflict
ghana is gravely concerned by the
reports of alleged cross violations of
international humanitarian law
and international criminal law since the
onset of the invasion
including emerging reports and images of
human rights violations and the killings
of civilians
in barrier pool
shannon
hakeef and areas on the outskirts of
kiev such as butcher
we support the call by the secretary
general for an independent impartial
and torah investigations to establish
the facts gather the evidence
and to hold all perpetrators of such
atrocious crimes accountable
for their actions
the killing of children the injured
medical personnel humanitarian workers
and journalists are deplorable
and we condemn all such acts
unreservedly
we add restraint on all sides and
re-emphasize the urgency
of an unconditional cessation of
hostilities nationwide
to enable the evacuation and safe
passage of civilians
and facilitate the delivery of
life-saving aid to the people in the
cities that remain under siege
humanitarian agencies require
unobstructed access to rich people in
need of food water and medicine and
other critical supplies
and all parties must guarantee such
access the ravages of both the global
coveted 19 pandemic and the situation
ukraine the moon demonstrates the
intercoordinatedness and interdependence
of states
and reinforce the need for a unified
international response in support of the
path of dialogue
and diplomacy
madam president we have followed closely
the direct negotiations between the
conflicting parties
and note the progress made in the fourth
round of consultations which took place
in istanbul on 29th of march 2022
to sustain the negotiations we edge a
restraint in their ongoing hostilities
and a follow-through of the express
commitments to resolve the security
concerns of the parties
in fragrance of the efforts of the
parties the council met at this time
focus attention
on supporting confidence-building
measures that facilitate a negotiated
settlement of the immediate conflict
and the wider question of european
security on the basis of international
law
and other internationally agreed
frameworks
the converges of the parties and the
international community on these matters
would be the only way to end the
tensions
bridge the differences between the
parties and forge a unified
position on the situation in ukraine i
thank you for your kind attention
i thank the representative of ghana for
his statement and i now give the floor
to
the representative of the united arab
emirates
thank you madam president and i'd like
to join others in congratulating you and
your team for assuming uh the presidency
and wishing you a productive month i'd
also like to thank uh the secretary
general the under secretary general for
political and peace building affairs and
the under secretary general for
humanitarian affairs and the emergency
relief coordinator for their helpful
briefings we also thank president
zielinski for his address to this
council
we have once again heard in this council
deeply sobering and concerning reports
from the ground including from martin
griffiths and rosemary de carlo and with
every meeting the council is reminded of
the rapidly deteriorating humanitarian
situation on the ground in ukraine one
quarter of the country's population have
fled their homes and the rising death
toll and the destruction of critical
civilian infrastructure are a grim
reflection of the tragic human cost of
war
the images coming out of bucha and other
towns and cities are shocking
the alleged crimes they entail are of
the utmost gravity and first and
foremost as others have said we must
establish what has happened here with
the cooperation of all parties
it is imperative that we do not get
caught up in a war of narratives in
addition to the conflict that is ongoing
indeed we need to allow for the existing
mechanisms to investigate the facts on
the ground impartially so that justice
for all victims can be served and we
acknowledge the secretary general's call
for that independent
investigation as well as last week's
appointment of the members of the human
rights council's independent
international commission of inquiry on
ukraine as we enter the sixth week of
conflict we believe that an immediate
cessation of hostilities throughout
ukraine is imperative
to move towards a peaceful solution to
the war in ukraine and we take note of
efforts to reach a diplomatic resolution
to the conflict and we see the ongoing
negotiations and several rounds of
negotiations between russia and ukraine
as a very positive development we remain
hopeful that these efforts at the
negotiating table can urgently translate
into de-escalation on the ground and we
urge others to support these efforts
we also welcome the readout from mr
griffiths on his meetings with senior
russian officials as well as his
upcoming meetings with ukrainian
officials
establishing a
viable humanitarian ceasefire could be a
stepping stone for broader negotiations
and eventually a sustainable peace
however until the cessation of
hostilities is achieved the priority
must be to work towards protecting and
alleviating the suffering of civilians
and in addition to the points we made
during the last council meeting on
ukraine on 29th march i want to focus
here on four additional points for the
council's consideration
first as others have done we all need to
continue to reaffirm
the need for all parties to abide by
their obligations under international
humanitarian law in particular the
protection of civilians and the respect
for the principles of distinction and
proportionality that are paramount in
conflict
second the difficulties in providing
relief and humanitarian access need to
be addressed immediately and can be
addressed quickly it's critical to find
either local or broad-based agreements
for security guarantees to allow for the
safe provision of humanitarian
assistance and for civilians to
voluntarily evacuate safely and these
are initial confidence-building measures
that can be developed down the line and
should also be encouraged including the
proposals left by mr griffiths
with the government in moscow
third as the icrc has noted
false narratives and disinformation
has the potential to cause real harm for
humanitarian organizations on the ground
the use of digital technologies that
amplify the spread of harmful
information including misinformation
disinformation and hate speech is a true
challenge in conflict zones and these
phenomena are not new
but technology has greatly increased the
scale and speed at which harmful
information reaches target audiences
online and this is particularly
concerning in crisis settings where
information can influence the dynamics
on behavior on the ground and can put
communities and humanitarian responders
at risk
fourth
at a time of conflict protecting
civilians of course must be our top
priority however we should not forget
the impact that war has on a nation's
cultural heritage and identity
we're concerned by unesco's recent
reports on the dozens of cultural sites
that have been damaged in ukraine since
the conflict began we know from our
experience in the middle east that
protection of cultural sites is critical
to rebuilding peace and in moments of
violence and turmoil cultural sites are
essential cornerstones for collective
memory and the foundation for future
reconciliation
we therefore call on all parties to
refrain from the unlawful destruction of
cultural heritage and to think about
what comes next after the war concludes
for the people living there and how they
go about building peace
before i end allow me to take a moment
to reflect on uh what others have
commented on including the secretary
general and that is the devastating
impact of the conflict on food security
worldwide and we're alarmed by these
figures shared by the secretary general
just now on how the war is affecting
some of the most vulnerable communities
around the world 1.2 billion people in
47 developing countries are at risk due
to rising food prices and food shortages
are aggravating situations already on
this council's agenda and these
shortages are felt in other settings
where high prices of basic commodities
can lead to further unrest and
instability not just in this part of the
world but around the globe so we look
forward to seeing the un global crisis
response group on food energy and
finance address these issues and offer
it our full support
and let us not forget that the effects
of this war are hitting communities that
are still reeling from the global covert
19 pandemic and these vulnerabilities
are further exacerbated by reduced
domestic food production
due to the rising costs and scarcity of
chemical fertilizers and pesticides and
the knock-on effects including global
conflicts will be grave and the council
must stay focused on all of them
unless we do something to end this
conflict now it will continue to drive
suffering and instability worldwide in
the coming months and years and the
world simply cannot afford this
and the security council should do its
part to stop this conflict and to help
parties come and reach a peaceful
solution thank you
i thank the representative of the united
arab emirates for her statement
and i will now make a statement in my
capacity as the representative of the
united kingdom
president zielenski
by video secretary general colleagues
the united nations was created
in the wake of a european war of
aggression
that laid waste to europe and engulfed
the
world all of us
who signed the un charter
committed to ending the scourge of war
to fundamental human rights
the dignity and worth of the human
person
the equal rights of nations large and
small
to justice and respect for international
law
yet now
we're facing another war of aggression
in europe
we've heard today
again
the devastating impact of russia's
unilateral and illegal military action
in ukraine
its impact on surrounding countries and
the region
and on the security and prosperity of
the wider world
as it seeks to recover from the covert
19 pandemic
thousands killed
millions displaced
cities raised to the ground
hospitals bombed
citizens cut off from food
water and medicine
blockaded seaports
and the rapid increase in wheat prices
pressure
on already stretched humanitarian
resources
and now
as russia is forced into retreat from
areas around kiev
the brutality of the invasion is laid
bare
we've all seen the horrific images
from the towns of butcher and european
of civilians deliberately killed in
areas
from which russian forces have we
recently withdrawn and the video we saw
earlier
underlined that horror
these acts and other credible incidents
must be investigated as war crimes
and the uk fully supports the work of
the international criminal court
and the work of the ukrainian prosecutor
general
and other national prosecutors
colleagues
as we and so many others have said so
many times
all of this could be stopped
if the russian federation ended this war
now i resume my function as president of
the council
the representative of the russian
federation has asked for the floor
to make a further statement
thank you madam president
i know that this does not bring us
closer to the end of today's meeting but
since today's topic is extremely
important
i think it's
essential essential to
to
say a few words about what was the
reason for this meeting which we didn't
have a chance to say yesterday because
we were not given a chance to have a
separate meeting of the security council
on this topic
unfortunately
yesterday's meeting
um
in any way possible our russian call our
western colleagues tried to to kind of
uh
sweep it under the carpet and we have
seen an example of how of the new order
based new rules based order
i would like to once again
focus on the events in bucha which
became the premise for conducting
today's meeting
and has led to some far-reaching
conclusions that many of you have
already made
all units of the russian armed forces
fully withdrew from bucha as a gesture
of good faith on the 30th of march
the very next
day after a
round of negotiations within russia and
ukraine in turkey in the presence of
negotiators
now a
report about this was published that
very same day on an official website of
the russian defense ministry during the
time that this the town was under the
control of the russian armed forces not
a single civilian
suffered from any kind of violence
people were able to move around freely
around the town and use their cell
phones
furthermore
the towns of the kiev
oblast
uh was
the russian the russian army supplied
450
450 tons of humanitarian assistance to
those cities this was confirmed
now the
the towns the russian army did not
prevent people from leaving the towns
all inhabitants could freely leave the
the towns uh toward the north
at the same time the southern the
southern areas of bucha including
residential areas
were shelled round the clock by
ukrainian forces
from using uh heavy caliber weapons
tanks and mortars
already after the withdrawal of the
russian forces the mayor of bucha
anatoly fedoruk in his video statement
on the 31st of march
presented this as a
heroic liberation of the city by the
ukrainian armed forces
now
let's set aside the so it's so called
liberation
and that's focus on the fact that he
confirmed the fact
on the 31st of march that
there were no more russian soldiers in
the town on the 31st of march
furthermore
the mayor did not mention
any local inhabitants with their hands
tied and having been shot
i mean could you believe that the mayor
would not have noticed on the streets as
as as reported of 280 corpses
he wouldn't have noticed that on the
first of april the deputy of the council
yekaterina ukraine
deputy council of bucha in a two-minute
video
uh warned it several times the
local residents
that representatives
of the ukrainian security forces have
entered the town and are conducting a
mop-up operation and
and she is asking she's asking everyone
to be very careful
now in on social media you can also find
an almost eight-minute video
about
the announced
mop-up of bucha by the ukrainian
national police on the 2nd of april
on that video there are no bodies of
civilians on the streets
furthermore on that video
the national guard of ukraine
also interviews local residents who
didn't mention any corpses or or or mass
shootings
on one of the ukrainian news sites there
was also warning posted
on the
upcoming
mop-up of bucha on the 2nd of april from
a mop-up of russian collaborators
now that's been deleted
but
users were able to to save that video
now testimony so-called testimony of
crimes or evidence of crimes by the
russian armed forces in bucha appeared
only on the third of april on the fourth
day after the the russian forces left
the town
once again without any evidence based on
the presumption of guilt
russian the russian army is being
accused of some some kind of evil deeds
of course we
we
we man
we could not notice how uh these
ukrainian videos were taken up by
western media and human rights
organizations who claim to be
impartial
and the clear clear inconsistency
between
uh between the the ukrainian version and
the actual facts is clear
if the corpses of of civilians had uh
been out in the open several days
they would have had several signs that
are well known to forensic specialists
and our western colleagues don't seem to
be bothered by that
otherwise the new york times would not
even go further by stating that the
corpses
were there on the streets since the 20th
of march can you imagine what kind of
state they would have been in
furthermore many
of
the those of the bodies
uh uh on in the videos circulated by the
ukraine had white uh bands armbands on
these are
these are armbands that were worn by
civilians after the entry of the russian
armed forces into the town
and one of the videos posted by
ukrainian radicals
you could hear a a call to shoot against
any to shoot anyone who doesn't have
blue arm
bands on
that
video during the
mop-up of uh
of bucha
was posted by a member of the
territorial
uh
defense battalion to whom the ukrainian
authorities handed out weapons
furthermore the member of the city
council of buchi who i mentioned
yekaterin ukraine
stated on the uh
website website meduza that
she did not see the russian forces
execute any civilians in the same
interview she she
confirms that is ukrainian armed forces
that are guilty of most of the
violations of course
these
these are details that have not uh
been mentioned in the uh presentations
of our western and ukrainian colleagues
however ukrainian uh president zielinski
is already
claiming that all these staged uh events
in bucha
have
give the the ukrainians the right for an
uncivilized response
well we can just imagine what that is
based on how ukrainian radicals behaved
in the east of ukraine
many testimonials of their of their
crimes are shocking
unfortunately
ukrainian experts on disinformation and
staging do not intend to stop there
as
the ministry of defenses claimed based
on confirmed information in the evening
of the fourth of april april in the town
of moshoon
23 kilometers to the to the northwest of
kiev
troops from the 72nd ukrainian main
center of psychological operations
conducted another
staged
staged video
of the so-called killing by
russian troops of civilians
for future for future circulation by
western media these kinds
of
activities
have been carried out by uh in suma and
other
towns so in conclusion i would like to
address my western colleagues we
understand very well
that
what you're doing
by by
by by fueling anti-russian uh hysteria
every single day so
we are uh assuming that there will be
uh
further
horrible provocations uh uh similar to
the one in bucha
new attempts
to discredit russian
soldiers and to present them as
murderers and rapists
i said once again that this is an
incredibly low blow
of course you're not interested in the
fact that modern technologies today
make it possible to create any video
we we watched a video today presented by
the ukrainian side today uh already
already the ukraine is full uh full of
uh
in fact
uh information refuting what was in the
video the stating that it wasn't
filmed in the right place with not the
right people and just a few words to my
american colleague
who who
declared a crusade to to exclude russia
from the human rights council
this is stated by a the representative
of a country who three years ago
criticized the council in the in the
strongest harshest terms
that it that that
that that it had the audacity of
condemning the actions of american
soldiers in afghanistan
and as is well known the
united states left the council
so i i hope that our colleagues from the
united nations
will
not
uh allow themselves to be manipulated
and play up to
washington and it's very dangerous
games thank you very much
i thank the representative of the
russian federation for his statement
the representative of ukraine has asked
for the floor to make a further
statement
well thank you
madam president
before
i switch to english i would say a couple
of words a couple of lines rather
we
uh i've become accustomed to the lies
that are
constantly being spewed
in this
in the chamber of the security council
uh
comrade nebenza
uh
decided to quote
from an interview
from a uh
media outlet called meduza i'd like to
ask comrade meduza
comrade nebenza excuse me why he doesn't
uh quote the interview in full
let me
let me quote that interview
who the representative of putin wanted
to use for his
purposes
i'm quoting
this is these are the words of the of
the woman who he mentioned and i'm
quoting
it
sometimes
russian soldiers
gave
dry rations
to the basement and then after after
lowering these rations they uh tossed
grenades into the basement
you wanted to quote that interview why
didn't you quote the whole interview
this is about your humanitarian
assistance
after which after you
provide that humanitarian assistance you
toss grenades that's an interview from
the same woman who you mentioned
english
i would like to make my further
statement in response to the
hypocritical questions
by putin's representative
after the video we
saw with the shocking images from
butcher
european
matajin
and other sites
he should ask these very
questions to himself
how have russians got to the cruelty of
nazis
when have you started enjoying acting
like nazis
killing civilians
attempting to withdraw internationally
recognized borders
setting the task to
finalize finally resolve the ukrainian
issue
like hitler attempted to resolve the
jewish issue
when did you miss the point of russia's
turning into the nazi-style cancerous
tumor
unable and unwilling to stop expanding
and bringing
to neighboring nations sufferings
destruction
pain and death
i am appalled over york cynical and
outright lie that you don't hit civilian
targets
and that is why you're moving so slowly
you hit the civilian targets and you
kill the civilians
shall i quote your own words of
yesterday in the press conference that
you gave here in the headquarters
where you said that civilians are killed
by your army
or shall i not
shall i play the video
you said it's this war
civilians are killed in the war
it's a warfare you said
or perhaps uh your mindset in your
mindset
at children's hospital in michaelave
destroyed by the russian strike
yesterday was a military target
and perhaps a child killed as a result
of the strike was a ukrainian
nationalist
the only truth you've said is that you
are not moving as planned
and the only reason
is the resistance of the ukrainian army
and the ukrainian people
not your smart military planning
the ukrainian people who realize
quite clear
what the russian world in reality means
and we thank the international community
for the solidarity with ukraine
ukraine will win
in this territory
and the entire world will win despite
the threats
that the criminal and the liar throws in
the face just in the security council
chamber
finally
if there is anything that we have to
thank the russian representative for
it is his acknowledgment
at the yesterday's press conference
that russia is waging war against
ukraine war you said several times
not the special operation
and i consider
this confession
shall impact the un assessment
of what is going on in the center of
europe
perhaps it was the unique moment
when we should believe
what a fully accredited representative
says in the united nations
hence once again
a reminder
to putin's diplomats
ribbon trope denied
any knowledge
of concentration camps
racial examination policies
yet was found guilty at nuremberg war
crime
trial
and we all know what happened to him on
the 16th of october 1946 i thank you
i thank the representative of ukraine
for his statement
i now give the flaw to his excellency mr
olof skoog the head of delegation of the
european union to the united nations
thank you madam president i address the
security council on behalf of the
european union and its member states
north macedonia montenegro and albania
bosnia and herzegovina iceland and
liechtenstein republic of moldova
georgia monaco and san marino all
aligned themselves with this statement
and i wanted to start by congratulating
you
madam president for the united kingdom
for assuming the presidency for the
month of april and for convening this
meeting and for inviting us to speak and
also acknowledge the presidency of march
of the united arab emirates
i want to thank the secretary general
this under secretary general de carlo
and griffiths for their presentations
and i want to express our full support
solidarity and respect for the heroic
people of ukraine as embodied by the
message this morning by president
zielinski
madam president 41 days ago russia
decided to wage a war of aggression
against ukraine in blatant violation of
international law
the principles of the u.n charter and of
the key of the osce an affront to the
rules-based order and to the global
security instability and we have heard
and seen again today the tremendous cost
to the people of ukraine
the dramatic consequences of russia's
war of choice are well known thousands
of life have been have been lost
over 11 million people most of them
women and children have been forced to
leave their homes over 500 schools and
52 hospitals have been shelled entire
cities have been raised to the ground
the unfolding drama in mario paul and
the images from bucha stain our common
humanity russia must stop this senseless
act of violence
the eu condemns in the strongest terms
russia's unjustified an unprovoked war
of aggression against ukraine we demand
that russia immediately stop its
military aggression immediately and
unconditionally withdrawal forces from
the entire territory of ukraine and
fully respect ukraine's territorial
integrity sovereignty and independence
within its internationally recognized
borders as demanded by the united
nations general assembly
we condemn in the strongest possible
terms the reported atrocities committed
by the russian armed forces in a number
of occupied ukrainian towns
haunting images of massacres with large
numbers of civilian deaths and
casualties as well as destruction of
civilian infrastructure show the true
face of russia's brutal war of
aggression
these massacres will be inscribed in the
list of atrocities committed by russia
on european soil
the russian authorities are responsible
for these crimes committed while they
had effective control of the area
they are subject to the international
law of occupation
russia is directing attacks against the
civilian population and is targeting
civilian objects including hospitals
medical facilities schools and shelters
these war crimes must stop immediately
those responsible will be held to
account in accordance with international
law
we welcome the international court of
justice's provisional measures ordering
russia to suspend military operations
immediately
we fully support the investigation
launched by the prosecutor of the
international criminal court into war
crimes and crimes against humanity as
well as the work of the independent
commission of inquiry
the eu is assisting the ukrainian
prosecutor general and civil society in
the collection and preservation of
evidence of the war crimes
it is clear there must be and there will
be
accountability the uns member states are
providing shelter for the more than 4
million refugees that fled russia's
violence they do so regardless of
nationality ethnicity religion or race
we have adopted sanctions against the
russian government its financial and
defense sectors and those individuals
enabling and financing the aggression
we have committed significant funding to
the u.n humanitarian flash appeal and
regional refugee response plans for
ukraine
so far the eu and its member states have
mobilized over 1.1 billion euros in
emergency aid
this comes on top of the 2.4 million
euros in humanitarian emergency and
early recovery assistance the eu and its
member states have provided to ukraine
since 2014
in the largest ever operation under the
eu civil protection mechanism 29
countries all eu member states together
with norway and turkey have responded to
the request for assistance from ukraine
as the 4th of april over 13 000 tons of
medicines hospital equipment ambulances
and firefighting equipment food and
energy supplies have arrived in ukraine
european leaders have set up a ukraine
solidarity trust fund to channel support
to post war post-war reconstruction
and at the pledging event on 9th of
april with canada we will further
showcase that we stand in words and
deeds with the courageous people of
ukraine
madam president after the security
council was unable to take action
the general assembly demonstrated once
again less than two weeks ago the
overwhelming international rejection of
the russian aggression and an
overwhelming support to addressing the
humanitarian crisis in ukraine
the international community demanded
safe and unhindered passage for civil
civilians fleeing violence as well as
humanitarian access to those in need
international humanitarian law must be
respected
the dramatic consequences of russia's
war against ukraine are not limited to
europe they are global ukrainian farmers
are prevented from sowing as a result of
russian shelling ships filled with wheat
and are blocked in black sea ports by
russian military forces as a result food
prices have rocketed
pushing people into poverty and
threatening to destabilize entire
regions the poorest countries as we've
heard are the most vulnerable to shocks
in food prices all this is a direct
result of the war despite russia's
cynical attempts to shift the blame
madam president the eu and its member
states are fully mobilized to end the
war in line with international law and
the u.n charter but at the same time
crisis the world over need our urgent
attention the eu will continue to
provide humanitarian and development
support to our partner countries from
north africa to the middle east and from
sub-saharan africa to asia
we are scaling up our multilateral
action to provide support to countries
with acute food insecurity and are
committed to keeping global trade routes
open so agricultural staples can feed
the world the eu has pledged 2.5 billion
euros for international cooperation
related to nutrition for the period
2021-2024
we also fully support the work of the un
to deliver and scaling up humanitarian
assistance protect refugees and work
towards the ceasefire
with a particular focus on food security
we will contribute to the work of the
global crisis response group to deal
with the global social and economic
effects of the war we heard your
recommendations this morning sector
journal and we have already launched a
strategy for safeguarding food security
and reinforcing the resilience of food
systems backed by increased assistance
madam president
once again we call on russia to cease
the destruction of innocent life across
ukraine and immediately and
unconditionally withdraw all its troops
we call for an immediate ceasefire safe
passage to civilians trapped in war
zones and uninterrupted humanitarian
access
we stand in solidarity with the people
of ukraine and all other people affected
by the war of russian aggression
we stand in support of ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and we will continue to work diligently
with the un and our partners to end this
aggression and address the humanitarian
needs i thank you madam president
i thank his excellency mr skoog for his
statement i also acknowledge the written
statements submitted by the delegation
of poland
uh in earlier before the meeting and
also from the eight nordic baltic
countries
there are no more names inscribed on the
list of speakers
the meeting is adjourned
you